[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show my guest
today is Todd McFarlane Todd is an Emmy
and Grammy winning director producer and
creator of one of the world's
best-selling comic books spawn he is
best known to many comic book fans for
his work as the artist on The Amazing
Spider-Man for which he co-created
Marvel's top villain Venom Todd is the
CEO of Todd McFarland Productions
McFarlane Toys one of the US's top
action figure manufacturers in McFarland
films he is also a co-founder of Image
Comics which debuted spawn in 1992
selling 1.7 million copies of the first
issue in 1997. spawn was made into an
Emmy award-winning animated series on
HBO and a live action feature film that
grossed more than 100 million dollars in
2019 Todd made history with spawn number
301 earning the Guinness world record
for the longest running creator-owned
superhero comic book series you can find
him online Instagram Todd McFarlane
Twitter Todd score McFarlane and
Facebook like Todd McFarland Todd it is
nice to see you again yeah thanks for
having me back Tim appreciate it and I
wanted to close the Marvel chapter and
I'll just explain for folks who are
hearing this episode first we recorded a
first episode which laid a lot of the
groundwork your background establish
your personality which I'm sure will
come through in this episode as well and
early days in comics many of the key
decisions negotiations your magical
capacity with your camel bladder to
inflict negotiating superiority on your
adversaries and many other things and I
thought we would put a pin in the Marvel
chapter by talking about Stanley and
perhaps you could just explain who Stan
Lee is and how you first developed a
relationship with him
probably most people have been paying
attention to movies uh already know who
Stan is but Stan is sort of the the
grandfather of
being one of the co-creators of all the
superhero characters that we all know by
name all right so if we go back
when Marvel first began
in in the early 60s he helped create he
was a writer and he helped create
characters like the Fantastic Four
Spider-Man Iron Man
the Hulk Doctor Strange Black Panther
the X-Men and on and on and on and on
and so
you know to put it in perspective really
when he passed away you know a few years
back
to me and I think a lot of people sort
of said the same thing you put them in
the same category as somebody like Walt
Disney in terms of the global impact
that his characters had not necessarily
him as a person
but that his characters had and so Stan
was a comic book guy for a lot of years
and then eventually moved out to
California in the in the 70s and
Odd as it is really sort of became a big
time celebrity when the movies came
around and he started making cameos in
the Marvel movies right so and he
started that when he was 85. so most
people don't begin a new career when
they're 85 Stan did and he did it so my
quick sort of
meeting with him first time I meet him
I'm about 16 17 years old
Canadian kid in Florida going to a
baseball camp and I happened to
stay overnight before we're going to
catch a plane go back home in the in the
Holiday Inn and there was a sign that
said down the hall
there was a comic book convention
I go down the hall
and Stan Lee again he's not the famous
celebrity at this point we're talking
now about the mid 70s and Stan Lee was
there and to me he was like the pope
because anybody who's ever read any
Marvel comic books at the top of every
Marvel comic books at that time said
Stanley presents he was in every book
Stanley presents every comic book I got
so I'm like wow there's Stan Lee the guy
who presents every Marvel comic book and
I walked up to him I wanted to break
into comics and I asked him hey Mr Lee
is it okay if I ask you a couple
questions and without hesitation he
pulled a chair right next to him and he
said sit down son ask me what you want
and he let me sit next to him for about
five hours peppering him with questions
now again he didn't have a big giant
lineup because like I said he was he
hadn't hit his celebrity status that
would come decades later but just that
he just said here you know
sit next to me you got questions until
when I went home to Canada that was one
of the moments where I went yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna really drive and do this
my next encounter with him now fast
forward I actually do break into Comics
I I climbed the rank and file that you
and I talked about in our first
interview I even get to do Spider-Man
which is sort of the corporate icon of
Marvel Comics that puts me on the map
and I set sales records with with those
books and then a bunch of us quit and we
start Image Comics and I end up doing
like a series of videos
would stand
in
1992-93 and sort of rekindling
a professional relationship
fast forward again
and
there's a I think it was Iron Man movie
was coming out and they were giving Stan
his own Todd I'm sorry to interrupt what
were those videos that you did with Stan
what was the content or the intention of
those videos that you did withstand
around 92-93. most of them are up on
YouTube they were just you know Stan and
I sitting there and he did it with a
couple of my other fellow artists and
you just sat at a table and you talked
art or you drew and you were talking
through your drawing have like how do
you create characters why does that guy
look like that right and it was just
sort of a almost a how how do you do it
sort of videos that were there did he
not view that as competitive since you
guys had split off to be
image at that point no Stan was very
entrepreneurial himself so at this point
he was doing you know he was almost an
ambassador for Marvel at this point
right and doing his own
stuff so the the interviews and the and
the videotapes were sort of under an
umbrella that was part of his own Camp
away from Mark he was in a full time got
it I think they were giving him a salary
to be like a good Steward going around
but he wasn't writing any books at that
point so got it yeah he was like the
professor emeritus of Marvel so sorry to
interrupt no no that's exactly what he
was and he was let me also say he was
very very generous in terms of
encouraging us even though he knew that
our books were going to be in direct
competition with Marvel good for him
because again he was a creative guy
right and haven't been around Stan as
much as I have been
his his superpower
to me besides he created all these
characters that none of us will ever
come close to I mean I got spawned he's
got like a hundred spawns
he and I saw it over and over and over
and all the times I was with him within
20 seconds because you have when you
have a big lineup and people are coming
for autographs you literally have 20
seconds with each individual and he
would make people feel important special
and unique in that 20 seconds and then
he would reset for the next person and
he would do it all over again for
thousands of people right they felt like
that was the best 20 seconds of Stan's
day
even though he was given it to every
single person right so it was it was
really a and I saw this when I was 16
when I was sitting with him for the
first time but I just kept becoming more
and more aware of this is how you treat
the public because the public without
them without the fans we have no careers
we are basically
self-indulging in our basements right
you can have ideas but if nobody is
consuming them and so because I I go to
shows and people go Todd why do you say
thank you to me we should be thanking
you it's like you give me money
every product you buy you give me money
you put food on my family's table like I
so if I if you get something out of me
cool but but I must thank you too
because I have a career because of your
existence which is why it's odd Tim that
I've run into enough celebrities whether
it's sports music you know movies TV
whatever it is and some are a little off
put by their fans right I mean they are
the reason we exist right and so I don't
know I I've never I've never and part of
it was looking at people like Stanley
I've never been put off by people
wanting to ask questions or whatever
else and I've had reporters ask me
especially during the whole you know
before comic books were sort of a cool
hip thing you know Todd what's the
dumbest question people ask is it like
Trekkie conventions here's the answer
there is no dumb question you know why
because whoever is asking it it's
important to them and if it's important
to them it's important for me to answer
it so even if the question may seem
silly to you because they want to know
who would win the Hulk or Thor in the
fight it's important to that individual
so I'm going to give them as good an
answer as I can and I'm not going to
look down my nose at them like you are
anyway withstand the big moment for me
in my relationship Stan is involved in a
cameo when the first Iron Man movie
comes out and the studio of Paramount
says hey we're going to give Stan his
own
movie premiere and they did it in Vegas
somebody phones me up and says hey Todd
can you come and be the MC of that thing
there's going to be a dinner or whatever
else and I went yeah yeah sure so I come
I get up there I say all the gracious
and true things about Stanley that I
believed and
everything goes cool and at the end Stan
comes up to me and says hey thanks
thanks young man that was quite that was
quite wonderful now I'm like oh thanks
appreciate you having me Stan the next
day and here's where it happens the next
day is I'm walking around the Vegas
hotel and I see Stan and he goes Todd
Todd hold us up hold up hold up and he
comes running over and he goes oh my God
you were wonderful last night you were
amazing last night and I went no no no
you you said that you said that to me
Stan and he goes no I didn't I can't
hear anymore I didn't hear a damn thing
you said last night but what they do is
that they record it and then I go to my
room and then I can actually put on the
headphones and then I heard it it was
wonderful all right because
he had just figured out how to be in
public with bad hearing and pull it off
so after he hears me I guess being kind
and and a little charismatic he says
Todd I go to conventions almost every
weekend
travel with me
and come with me around the country and
you and I let's team up now
gracious offer Stan I've got a day job
right so I can't I can't I mean I
understand Batman you would like me to
be a robin and it's very very
complimentary but I've got to do it but
I said when I can
I will so I did from that point on I did
I've probably been up on stage with Stan
more than any human being on the planet
right and we we had this little schtick
and part of it was at the beginning
because literally Tim he could not hear
so what he needed was somebody who could
hear and then turn and slightly give him
the question or frame it in a way that
made sense for a Comic Book Guy where a
lot of times moderators didn't know the
comic book sort of lingo and so we just
sort of had this weird kabuki dance we
were doing so that he could hear now it
came to a crescendo one time where we
were
in San Diego and he was up on stage and
you know how when you I mean it was a
big room with probably 5 000 people and
you know they put up the big giant
screen so the people at the very back
can at least look at the video right
video screen
and Stan was in the middle and I usually
sit next to him but I go no stand this
is your gig I'm going to be over here on
the podium just talking and and Stan we
start doing our thing
and next thing I know I'm talking and
I'm sort of not paying attention because
I'm looking at the audience and then I
turn and Stan is literally six inches on
my flank
and then I look up at the screen because
the screen wasn't mobile the camera was
fixed and the camera like
the stage was empty because he had
screwed it so far over I so I look at
him under my breath go stand you're
you're off screen there's no you're not
on TV all the people in the back you go
but he's like what go and talk I can't
hear a damn thing I can't hear it then
So eventually he got a hearing aid and
like all of a sudden the heavens opened
up and he was like oh my God Todd I
should have done this years ago but we
still even once he got the hearing aid
we still did our stick doing it and to
the point where
and there's a photo that to me is
one of the Dearest photos that I have in
my collection outside of my family it
was we were in Phoenix which where I
live and we were doing our thing it was
a little small convention here and we
were up on stage
this is post his wife passing away and
so that mattered in his life I was there
I got to bring him up on stage when he
you know got his Hollywood Walk of Fame
star and you know with the Chinese man
theater right I was sort of like his guy
to bring him up on stage
so I was there for a couple important
moments of him but and I'd gone up on
stage so many times he had so much
energy and as we walked up the stairs at
that one in Phoenix he turned to me and
said
Todd you do most of the talk and I don't
want to be here it was the first time
ever
that I didn't hear
enthusiasm out of that man right and I
mean he was already old and I saw it
when he arrived that he looked as old as
I ever saw him
anyways we did our interview and we took
I we used to take these selfies I got
all these cool pictures of me and him
taking selfies because he never
understood what a selfie was so he was
always like right jammed his face jammed
into the lens so I got these cool
awesome photos he also in the green room
before we went up he used to take a nap
because he was in his 90s he used to pay
himself so I've got all these cool
pictures of me making faces around him
while he's napping right so I'm gonna
put a whole book out it's gonna be nap
time withstand I'm gonna publish
something but he walked up there and
when he said those words it was a dagger
in my heart and we did our interview we
took the selfie we walked off stage and
that was the last time he was ever on
stage and he shortly passed away and I
kicked myself because one you have a
couple regrets that was one that I wish
we knew that was going to be the last
time that he was going to be
on a stage in his lifetime because we
would have sent them off with a better
with a better Applause than we did that
day but uh anyways he was a like I said
I was fortunate even after he stopped
going to shows I was one of the few
people that was
allowed to be in his house because there
was in fighting amongst some five thumbs
around him especially like I said once
his wife went away
but the last time I went and saw him
you know I I go hey Stan how are you
doing but and he said
Todd I I can't see
I can't hear
I can't go to shows and Joni which is
his wife and Joni's not here I just want
to be with Joni
and it was
because she only had his two things was
he had the love of his life
his wife almost married 70 years those
two people 70 years
and and when she left you can imagine he
lost his soul mate and then the only
thing he had left was the conventions
and once his hearing and his eyesight
went completely he couldn't go to that
both the things that were sort of
important to him left and he sort of
broke down at the end it was it was that
because again and here's the thing we're
talking here's the thing we're talking
about a guy who up to the age of 93 was
doing cartwheels up on stage so we never
allowed him to be old we never gave him
we were literally doing cartwheels no
you're just being energetically oh yeah
I'm saying 93 he got up there you throw
him a question and he just went at 93 he
was at the top of his game 94 he passed
away at 95. he was still at the top of
his game on stage and we and part of it
was he was so
Immortal to us that we never acknowledge
that he was in his 90s we just thought
he was like some 50 year old guy with a
lot of energy but eventually time came
and he had to leave us
you spent so much time with Stan and
you observed so many things picked up on
so many things firsthand and then as an
observer for instance the energy that he
could summon the focus that he could
summon to be with each person for 20
seconds and then reset which is
really a skill and a talent and very
taxing
so that is extremely impressive in and
of itself are there any other
lessons or
learnings that you
took from Stan or things that still come
up that lead you to sort of Reminisce
about
sort of the the University of Stan as it
were spending time with him
I'll comment on two things number one
the stand that was on stage was the same
man off stage it wasn't a put on right
it wasn't a put I mean I've got
recordings usually let me record him
and he'd be in the taxi and pick me up
at
you know the airport and the whole drive
from the airport to the hotel he'd be
like why is Todd here I don't like it
when the good looking guys are here he's
taking too much and he would just do
this whole thing where he was just like
jabbing me the whole drive because you
know we did a lot of it up on stage
so again it was important but
I remember and here's the last thing
I'll say I remember
dozens of times
of him being in the green room as we're
getting ready
to go up on stage or something and he
would turn to me and it would just be
him and I and he would go Todd
isn't this wonderful
isn't this great I'm having a great time
this weekend he goes who would have
thought guys like you and I we're
nobodies and look at this we're having
the best time and so what I'm saying is
that the reason he was able to summon
that energy is because he was getting as
much out of the audience as they were
getting out of him it was chicken noodle
for his soul when he went to the shows
which is why when his wife was sick Joni
she said don't stop going to the shows
even after I'm gone don't you need it
and to you know to his credit he did he
kept going but he yeah he liked being
there and so it wasn't a put on like I
said I've been around a lot of
celebrities and I think in all honesty
Tim of all the celebrities I've been
around I have you know obviously
I haven't climbed the mountain of a lot
of others but if all the celebrities had
been around all the time I spent if I
was to pick one person to write the book
how to interact with your fans by far
Stanley's the guy who would do the how
to do it
amazing
Stan
I mean I remember as a collector seeing
the Masthead as a little kid right and
then even into my area
of course yes Stan Lee and then I also
correct me if I'm getting this wrong but
the voice that you actually impersonated
really well for people who don't know
would come on some of the early cartoon
adaptations yes and his voice would come
on and I would see that every morning
eating my cereal getting ready to go to
school so Stanley for me also had this
iconic
pope-like importance as a little kid uh
you know in a childhood experience where
that doesn't really exist you know it's
like who's this Mythic Stan Lee I tell
you another little silly story we were
in the trailer again the equivalent of
green room waiting to go up on stage and
I was sitting with Stan and they were
talking about him doing his cameos he'd
done three or four cameos in a row and I
went oh yeah and I don't really go to
the Marvel movie so you know I don't
know the next one coming up was Thor and
it was they were the commercials were
running and I kept seeing the commercial
and he had short hair Thor had short
hair and to me I'm like what Thor's got
long hair it's weird
and so anyways I'm talking to Stan we're
in the trailer and I go oh you got to do
some more cameos oh yeah the Thor what
did you do in the Thor one and he goes
um let me think I'm trying to remember
oh yeah I think I was the barber and I
went what he goes yeah I do this thing
where I'm the barber and I go so what do
you do he goes I cut Thor's hair hold
his ex then you're saying I've been
seeing this commercial he's got short
hair you cut his hair and he's like yeah
yeah yeah yeah I cut his hair it's like
this weird thing where I've got this big
blade and I've got bad eyesight and
they're pinning him down and I'm going
oh my gosh that's the coolest thing and
then I just went oh man if we only had
like a pair of scissors we could reenact
that he goes I'll get a pair of scissors
taught and he actually went and found
the pair of scissors and then he
literally reenacted I videotaped it
where I'm Thor and they're holding me
down and he's saying his lines and he's
like going God he's doing all of it so
he like I said I get we're about to go
on stage but he's still just goofing
around right I mean he had the one
someday I'll release it that is arguably
the best piece of video I have from Stan
because he was a very kind polite gentle
man in terms of his language if you will
when he was up on stake
and I have the one where I recorded
where he goes Todd
can I tell you something again out of
the blue can I tell you something yeah
Stan you say whatever you want do you
know what the most
flexible word is in the English
dictionary that has the most ways you
can use it and I want no Stan
[ __ ]
like I had never I don't even think I
ever heard him even say damn up to this
point not even around him a lot and it
sort of shocked me right park pardon
yeah dog [ __ ] and then he went on a
dissertation of how you can use that
word as a noun a pronoun an adjective
and gave examples of all of them it was
like a school teacher
sort of doing a classic master class and
how to use a word more than once it just
happened to be that word so maybe
someday that that audio will come out
well it seems like in the maybe the
appendices of the how to interact with
your fans book that he would author you
would have how to enjoy life and not
complain as the supplemental materials
he seems like he's very good at
enjoying life pausing not getting swept
up
in
all the superficial nonsense but
stopping you and saying isn't this great
like let's look at this for a second
like isn't this amazing it seems like he
was able to really harness
his appreciation in a way that maybe fed
him and allowed him to get to his mid
90s still doing the metaphoric
cartwheels on stage
that's something that comes across in
the stories I think Stan he comes from
the school of those of us who believe
are 15 minutes of fame is just about
over every day we wake up right we
always think tomorrow is the day where
they're gonna understand that we're
imposters and that there's way more
important people that are more skilled
that have more to say and
all of a sudden you go to your next show
or you go to your next and there's
another group of people and you go wow I
guess it's going to last one more day
right and you keep going and you're
thankful for it right
and so again at some point once you know
that you're fortunate
that's okay I mean at my end I think
there's a little bit of canadiana in it
I was born in Canada you know I saw
people like Steve Nash and Wayne Gretzky
my my big personal hero
sort of act like Gentlemen even though
they were Superstars and I think part of
it is and you know maybe overstating it
but you know when you're from Canada you
know that the big brother is America and
that's where all the big action is and
if you can get any
attention and you can even infiltrate
down there you always are sort of
looking over your flank going eventually
you're going to see that they can just
pick one of their own they don't need us
right and so you see that with a lot of
comedians that come from Canada and
actors come from Canada that we just and
so I stand sort of had a little bit of
Canadian in him where he was just like
enjoy it while you can you don't know if
it's going to be here tomorrow like your
health right so yeah so Todd it seems to
me or at least it seemed to me when I
was younger and even now in some
respects like once a comic guy always a
comic guy however
you have managed to Branch out and
infiltrate all of these different areas
and I don't even know how to put them in
order so you've got McFarland toys right
so let's just generically lay it out you
got toys music directing TV film
what is the order of how you entered
those various things so you're
forging New Paths setting records that
image yes when do these things start to
pop up and in what order
in all honesty Tim there's they're a bit
scattered so let me let's go see if we
can go through them real fast all right
let's just talk
first about
how the toys come to be real quickly
okay
we start Image Comics we talked about
that in the last show Image Comics the
third largest comic book company you
know in North America Marvel DC and then
Image Comics if you ask who's three
that's us for 30 years in a row
and because of that when when we came
out in 1992 that was when we first came
out and spawn came out in 1992 we're
celebrating the 30th anniversary of both
of those this year
spawn went to the top of the charts
right set sales records at the top of
the charts and I'm not saying for
independent comic books I'm saying top
of the charts for comic books it was
ahead of every Marvel and every DC comic
book
and so you can imagine when you have
something at the top of a chart then
people in other Industries come around
and they start knocking on your door and
so people were coming and knocking on my
door going oh my God spawn is at the top
of the charts you want to do pajamas and
pillowcases and toothbrushes and all
these ants what they call ancillary
merchandising and so all those phone
calls were coming now I gently said
no no no no I want I understand you want
to do pillowcases but do you know have
you read a Spawn comic book was like
well no but we see it's number one so do
you know the wrong answer for Todd yeah
do you know he's from Dakota right like
and you can just shoot there's a
hesitation they're going jungle why
don't you take a couple of the issues
from this characters from the pit of
Hell go read a couple and then decide
whether you want to do pillowcases for
kids that are five years old now a bunch
of them didn't follow up with their
phone calls after I sort of put their
nose in the product all they saw was
that spawn was ahead of Spider-Man and
Batman and Superman so it must be super
awesome right that was it that was all
their homework was at that point
so here's what I had in the back of my
mind when we left Marvel comic books and
we we helped start image comic I wanted
to build a foundation because I feel
that you know metaphorically if you can
build a strong Foundation just like in
the real world you can put a skyscraper
on a strong Foundation how do we know
because they exist right so the
foundation to me was could I do movies
TV video games and toys those were the
four those were the four cornerstones
got it because I felt that if you could
get your brand into those four corners
then again because I was playing in the
comic book world then I could Branch out
into these areas and and plant some
corners and get people to go oh and it's
work because I know people who've since
say I know Spawn from HBO not because
I've read the comic or bought the toys
it was they saw it on HBO or wherever I
don't really care let me just tell you
Tim I don't really care my attitude is
building a business you build a house
that's your business and you put as many
doors on your house as possible and you
make sure they're all unlocked all the
time I don't care how they get into the
house I don't care how they come to the
party it's party central inside the
house right I don't care if they go Todd
man I saw you did that music video I
don't care doors open come on in come on
in come on in I don't care how you got
here I am not discriminating on on a fan
because the bigger your army is the
collective whole the better chance you
have of then sending out your message
for the next thing that you're about to
do and it might work so those were the
four pillars one of the pillars and and
to go through them real quick I made a
deal with the video games I made the
deal with HBO and we'll get back to that
on the TV uh new line Cinema
we made the deal with the movie and then
we got to the toys and all the the the
Fortress 500 the public companies came
to my door and they all gave their
presentation some of them were pretty
elaborate they had prototypes and
everything and I just felt
at the end of it I just go I don't think
they get it
what I heard was they're going to do
traditional toys and put them in
traditional places and Market them in
traditional ways which basically meant
they were going to put spawn next to
Teletubbies and all their Disney
products and I thought it was a recipe
for failure and oh by the way if I gave
it to him and it failed then when it
didn't work which I thought it wouldn't
they would hand me my brand back and it
would be tainted how do I how do I then
pick up those pieces when people go ah
it failed last time Todd why would we
want now to dust it off and try it again
so I I never felt like I could get what
I wanted and so that you have to then
ask the next question
how hard is it to make my own choice
that's it right so sometimes it's out of
anger I've started companies just
because I got pissed off it's because
people think that what they're doing is
way way more complicated than it is let
me let me tell you something right now
Tim
we've got the Image Comics and we do our
own comic books and we're doing you know
what making comic books is at its core
Inc on paper period period period ink on
paper the toys are not that much
different it is plastic in the shape and
if you have the right mold you can make
a shape how do I know anybody who's kind
of old that remembers this when we were
kids remember you used to get these
little trays and and they're in the
shape of dinosaurs and then you pull you
poured the jello into it and you put it
in the fridge and then you flip it out
and all of a sudden your Jello look like
dinosaurs you know why because that was
what the mold looks like so toys are
plastic in jello molds essentially a
little bit of a little bit more detail
so I'm leaving out but essentially that
sort of it so when I asked the question
how do you make toys how do you make
comics how do you make almost anything
it's not they want let me tell you the
people in that industry the people that
are the leaders in that industry always
want you to think that it's way more
complicated always want you to think
that it's basically on undoable and will
never ever sidestep no matter how good
your idea is to let you pass them if
anything they will intentionally try and
trip you as you're passing them and tell
you can't be done can't do it will will
hire people away from it they'll they'll
tell you everything stop rocking the
boat why don't you just get along you
everything that you can possibly imagine
why they don't want competition they
don't want competition so at some point
you have to shut all that stuff down and
go I don't care I don't care if I sell
five I'm good enough and it was my money
again the whole thing spend other
people's money I disagree one hundred
percent spend your own damn money you
know why because nobody gets to tell you
what to do so if you want to go buy a
car with polka dots on it and it's your
money do it and drive it with a smile on
your face and if somebody doesn't like
it tell them to buy their own damn car
right but the moment you take somebody's
money and they get to tell you whether
they like the polka dots on the car or
not and so I just go no I spent my own
cash when I started the companies and I
was fortunate because the comic books
were paying royalties I wasn't getting
paid a lot let me just tell you I wasn't
getting paid a lot per page
that's not what made me just so
everybody know at the height of my
career at Marvel I was making 125
dollars per page that was the max they
were paying it was the royalties I was
getting a percentage of the sales and
that was the magic of it it's what
literally made us economically at Image
Comics because we were getting four
percent of the profits and when we went
and started our own company guess what
we're getting a hundred percent so do
the math if you take 100 divided by four
if we were selling one twenty fifth
right one twenty fifth the amount of
books that we were doing at Marvel we
would make the same money and guess what
boys and girls we sold the same
we sold the same in some cases more than
we were selling at Marvel so we were
then all of a sudden instantly making 25
times more than we were overnight and
that's a whole another you could use
that to bankroll the toy development
correct you're a piece of that correct I
wasn't spending it I wasn't buying fancy
cars I wasn't doing anything I'm kind of
a tight ass when you get right down to
it I was just putting it in a corner for
rainy days or when I was going to get
angry and I because I knew my
personality
so we started the toy company and
and we came out with the First toys
action figures at that point were 5.99
and I priced mine at 6.99 and here's the
thing here is the thing if you're
listening to my voice all the big
companies came to me and patted me on
the back and went little boy
you can't sell a 699 toy they're 5.99
here's the answer of course you can of
course you can here's how you sell a
6.99 toy give them 6.99 of value period
oh I I'll even give you an upgrade give
them 7.99 a value and price it at 6.99
what they were thinking because they're
the big corporate guys how do you sell a
5.99 toy for 6.99 I get that you can't
sell that because people will understand
you're overpricing it I'm saying build a
Cadillac and sell it at Ford motor
prices and you can sell that all day
long because people understand value and
they can do it because I didn't have any
big Brands I didn't I didn't have
Superman and Batman or Star Wars I had
spawn and there was only one way I was
going to be able to compete with those
big names just give them better quality
and give them more plastic nothing like
again never underestimate plastic it's
like saying do you want the 15-ounce bar
of chocolate for a dollar or the 10
ounce bar of chocolate I'll take the 15
what are you talking about always take
the bigger bar right for a buck take
more chocolate right come on man so I
was the I was the guy who was just
giving them more and more and more how
did you learn about making toys and
figure out the process for making
quality products like how did you
educate yourself
on the
bits and pieces and steps and right way
to approach it slowly
I did it slowly no no so when I finally
hung up my last meeting with somebody
wanting to take the rights of Spawn to
make them toys and I said no
I I got on the phone I knew a couple
people and I phoned somebody who was
sort of entrepreneurial and I said you
know anybody that makes toys and they're
going oh yeah yeah I got a couple
buddies and we got on the phone with
them and that was it and they just went
yeah I've been involved in making toys
and we and that was it and it was you
sculpt the toy out of clay back then you
can do it digitally now but back then it
was out of clay and then you send that
you know make a mold of it and you send
it over to your factory and most toys
are manufactured in China we found
factories in China and
they cut a steel mold and they go how
many do you want and you're Off to the
Races right so again
I mean it's more complicated than that
but at its core it's not it's not really
if you've got art you can make art in
any shape you want and so for me what
what helped me Tim more than anything
else and I've said this I've never I've
never invented anything original I've
never done anything new what I've done
is taken everything that I've seen with
my eyes and just made it sexier and
cooler period that's it that's the
recipe everybody who's out there is
listening and wants to be an
entrepreneur stop putting the pressure
on yourself to think you have to come up
with something new and original you do
not you just have to add three percent
sexy to it and you will now be the
genius let's give you an example I'll
give you an example 10 12 years ago
there was a guy named Steve Jobs you may
have heard of him and he went up on
stage one day and he said ladies and
gentlemen I remember the day he there
was a bunch of people and he goes ladies
and gentlemen
we are Apple and we are because they
were doing iPods and go we're gonna come
out with a phone
and the people in the audience one uh
Steve a little late to the game phones
have been out for a while cell phones
have been up for a while a little late
no no no no no no no no but get this
ours can die old people already been
done Steve and we text done and photos
done download stuff done email done done
done there's nothing you're doing Steve
that hasn't been done and then the
moment and then the moment he said yes
but
when you text hi Mom on their phone you
are touching a QWERTY with plastic
buttons and when you say hi Mom on mine
you're not touching plastic you're
touching glass boom
boom it did the exact same thing as
every other phone on the marketplace
except you touched glass that was the
genius he gave them the sexy glass
instead of plastic still have to put
h-i-m-o-m hi Mom it's still the exact
same thing he just figured out the three
percent if you can figure out the three
percent on any idea they'll make you a
genius so what's the genius they've
given me Tim oh my gosh Todd
we've done Sports
figures
for decades oh my gosh I've won awards
oh my gosh Todd your toys are so
detailed and so realistic how do you do
it you're asking the wrong question the
question should be how did they not do
it I'll tell you how I do it easy we use
this high tech if you don't understand
the high tech go to Google it's called a
camera and if you take a camera and you
push the button it gives you a photo and
if you take the photo and you take your
clay and you do not stop manipulating
the clay until it looks like the photo
then it looks exactly like it the
question isn't how did I make my toys
look realistic the question is how did
they not because the camera has been
around for a hundred years if not more
how did they not use the tool and so I
use Photo reference and I'm a genius let
me tell you Tim another rule of life if
you want to be smart act and hang around
dumb people because why is using photo
reference get me Awards it shouldn't it
shouldn't but God bless dumb people so
those are for the athletes is that what
you're talking about the the photographs
yeah yeah that was it yeah yeah making
toys back then is just manipulating clay
will go into any position and pose and
shape you wanted to the question is I
wasn't doing anything original I was
just putting the clay in a different
shape they had clay too and they've been
making toys for 50 years why they chose
not to put it in those shapes I don't
know go ask them but some of it Tim
became crystal clear to me as I broke
into the business why they didn't do it
because if they did the detail that I
did they would then have to paint it
yeah ah and here's the magic that every
time you put paint on a toy that's a
penny
oh now we got to paint that oh a penny
oh a penny oh a penny and eventually
they go that's 7 8 10 12 extra cents we
can't do that why because we're making
tens of millions of toys times 12 cents
it just becomes a number they're in the
business to maximize shareholder profits
every 90 days they're not their job
isn't to be great artists it's to
maximize margins and profit so they go
we need to make 10 million how do we
make the toy we got to manufacture it
for 98 cents I do the opposite Tim I go
make the product as good as you can
price it afterwards and if it's a value
people will pay you the money it's why
people will pay
ten thousand for one car and other
people will give you seventy thousand
for another car they believe there's a
value in that price and that they say
that at Toys R Us they're going you
can't have a toy at eight or nine bucks
people won't give you eight or nine
bucks for a toy or whatever of course
back then of course they will because
they're walking in another aisle giving
you 200 for a Playstation if people
think that there is value they will give
the money to you just make value price
it afterwards but they don't and so they
were cheap they were making cheap ugly
toys God bless them I was able to come
in and make mediocre toys and I look
like a genius
to two things real quick on that the
first is for people who
don't have a lot of exposure to toys and
I'm not even sure I mean there's there's
a maybe a blur between toys and
sculpture on some level but I just came
back from Japan where I went to a
showroom where they have in effect toys
they don't have many movable joints or
anything like that
that sell for thousands of dollars yeah
I mean they cost as much as a car and
they're video game characters that have
been
have been morphed into these beautiful
three-dimensional
in effect plastic sculptures so there's
always a market for high quality and at
a price high quality at a price how did
you think about distribution you didn't
want to be right next to the Teletubbies
so what did you do okay here's where
Beggars and choosers come look I've said
to people before if you're going to have
any amount of success in your life one
of the one of the people you have to
hang around with is that guy named dumb
luck right that has to come he has to
come be a visitor every now and then
right so I'm gonna give you my dumb luck
moment in comic books I hate to say it
my dunluck moment was that an artist on
a book died literally died and there was
an opening remember okay so he's dead
Todd break for you not good for him good
for you my big break in toys and
do not do what I'm just about to say
because I don't think this lightning is
going to strike in the same place a
couple times I went to Toy Fair Toy Fair
in New York City comes once a year and
this is where everybody brings all their
worldly Goods at that time this was back
in 1994 Hasbro let's just take a big toy
company or Mattel they had their own
building 10 stories high filled with
everything and the buyers would go into
that building Circle the floor one go up
the floor two and go all the way up and
down 10 floors I on my first toy fair
was in a building that only had five
floors I was on one floor but on that
floor there was 20 rooms I was in one
room and that room was cut into 40
pieces Myspace was five feet by five
feet okay now I'm at Toy Fair I'm in
this little corner here and even dumber
than that Tim I don't even have a
prototype this is how stupid I was I
didn't even bring a prototype we didn't
have time to get it done what would you
bring
sorry keep going I don't want to
interrupt but I'm just sick what the
hell I'll tell you what I brought a
drawing of spawn on foam core and I cut
it out so I go it's gonna look sort of
like that drawing right that was it that
was my cell that was my whole speech and
oh by the way I had made some Hot Wheel
toys based on a funny card that I had
bought and and I'd hand them the
the Hot Wheel okay and now the moment
now the moment at this point Toys R Us
is number one toy buyer not Walmart and
pretty soon Walmart's gonna crush them
probably within six months but at that
point Toys R Us is the toy buying gods
and then we're in this room with 40 of
us with our little like a bad swap meet
when I was a kid and the door opens up
and everybody stands up and snaps like
they're in an army barracks and the
sergeant has come in and I'm like huh
what's that about now again the room was
so small that you had to come down like
a little bit of a walkway and then bend
there was there was a jog and I was
around the jog so I didn't know I just
saw people stand up and present
themselves in front of their beds and
it's like okay and so I go around the
corner to see and I go who is that and
they're going oh my God
that's the buyer from Toys R Us and it
was like the pope had come into the room
and it was like oh my God so I was
watching him come and as he's walking
closer and closer down towards where I
was standing if he walked by you he
wasn't buying anything
so it was really kind of cool to
visually I still have this moment where
it's like as you walk by people you
could just see them collapse physically
because it's like oh [ __ ] he's not
buying that and he keeps walking by and
then you'd be like oh crap oh crap oh
crap oh crap oh crap and then I went oh
I guess I better go stand by my Barrack
too uh in my bed and so I stood in front
of my little thing and they come around
the corner
and guess what the Toys R Us buyers
stopped at my my place now
Tim did this buyer care about spawn no
did he even know who spawn was no did he
know who I was of course he didn't so
why did he stand there this is the
moment he had an assistant and the
assistant was looked like he was about
21 or 22 and then the magic word hey
boss this is the guy I was talking to
you about now remember at this point
spawned the comic book is number one in
the nation
so he basically this kid I don't even
remember his name I own my career to
this dude
and when he said this is a guy I'm
talking to you about and all that Toys R
Us buyer said he's just looked at it and
just went
let me ask you a question
can you get it to me at this price yes
sir did I know if I could Tim of course
I didn't always say yes to any
opportunity always say yes to any
opportunity figure out whether you can
actually do it later
can you give me that pressure of course
I can't can you deliver it on this date
uh of course I can
fine if you do that I didn't know if I
could either I didn't even have
factories at that point and so he goes
if you can do that I'll put you in all
my stores I'll go store wine holy [ __ ]
and just so you guys know usually if
they take a sample they don't usually
put you store wide but he said I don't
know who his assistant was he must have
been bending his ear he goes I'll put
you store wide I went yes sir so he left
all of a sudden all the other people in
the room came around me because it was
like oh my God like I just won the lotto
yeah oh my God oh my God and then this
is why those moments matter I couldn't
even get a meeting with Walmart and
Kmart and Target and those people back
then and now all of a sudden I'm in
Walmart's room and I get to now say well
just to let you know I've got the spawn
product and it will be going store-wide
in Toys R Us Now does Walmart know
anything about me respond of course they
don't of course they don't but what they
don't want to do is get beat by their
competition so they go Toys R Us going
store wide yeah okay we'll take some
and then the dominoes I go to Kmart and
Target and all these other places and
then you just keep adding well Toys R Us
and Walmart are on board and they're
like what what are we missing and it
just becomes this thing and next thing
you know I'm in all these big stores and
I go wow without even having so much as
a prototype it doesn't usually work that
way now once you get into the store
you must now sell because people go wow
Todd you got your product selling at
Walmart or whatever is that although
we're skipping a few steps how did what
was the hardest part of figuring out how
the hell to make that volume of toys
because I'm just thinking about The
Upfront cost right so thinking at
thinking about it from the standpoint of
Toys R Us they're like okay great we'll
give you net 90 terms we have the
ability to return all of them if they
don't sell like it could just kill you
financially I would think no they don't
return them okay no they don't okay all
right tell me more because like if it
was like a Home Shopping Network or
something I don't think this is
absolutely accurate but with some
retailers they have all these terms that
can just Crush you if it's a lot of
inventory I've been fortunate enough
that both toys and comic books are if
you order it it's yours okay all right
so you go okay what you want to do on in
the toy side is to make sure that
they're not over buying both parties
need to be realistic right and it's one
of the reasons I think Tim that I've
survived as long as I have because I've
talked them down from orders which is
actually the opposite of what they're
used to yeah which I go I know you want
75 000 units of that but you know what I
think why don't we start you at 40. I'll
build some inventory it'll be on my
nickel and if you need more then we'll
just Supply you as you need I think if
you buy 75 because here's the math just
so everybody knows do you buy 75 and you
sell 60.
they're going to go ah I got 15 000 in
inventory it's not a success if you give
them 40 and then they have to buy
another 20
and they sell 60 they go wow we ordered
50 more than our original order yeah so
you're still at 60. but one they're
disappointed and one they're not so you
have to sort like you're still playing
some weird Mind Games a little bit so
that they feel good about whatever
number was there and so to me again and
I'm not a public company and I don't
have to maximize profits right my goal
is I've told all my employees get me to
zero every year and we get to do it
again for another year right so as long
as we're money in Money out short is
about the same let's keep doing it right
I'm okay I don't need to impress anybody
my kids I've already paid for their
college or off the house is paid for
we're good right we're like my wife and
I are good so is the paired directive
just like let's make the best
stuff we possibly can I mean there's
probably a couple of paired principles I
would imagine that go with that that was
yeah the company came from one simple
question why can't toys be cooler again
I was looking at it from an artistic
point of view I wasn't asking it from a
business point of view again again you
find out what that means when you ask
that question and so I go why can't they
make cooler toys I found out Tim that
the reason they weren't making cooler
toys is because again like I said every
time they put or did an extra joint or
an extra movement or an extra paint job
or something it was pennies and it just
added up and so I ran into this thing
where I was I I had my prototypes at Toy
Fair because I started actually making
prototypes and each year I would bring
them and we we would sculpt at twice the
size of the final product why because
the bigger you sculpt it the more detail
you can put in it and when you shrink it
down it holds the detail so I would
bring I would bring these sculpts and
I'd bring them to the showrooms and the
buyers would go yeah Todd they look
really really really nice I get it but
what's the product going to look like
it's never going to look like this and I
went what are you talking about it's
going to look exactly like this and I'm
like silly boy that's not how it works I
found out because I spied on Hasbro and
Mattel and all the big guys I was able
to get into their showrooms that they
were doing this thing where they would
bring these prototypes out that were
awesome think of them as like the
concept cars at an auto show but you
never will see those cool cars right
they're just they're they're eye candy
and I'm I remember seeing this one toy
that was super awesome and went wow
that's good and then I saw it like
months later literally at the store and
it was blue plastic
they didn't put even a drop of paint on
it so what I ended up having to do
because I was paying for the sins of
these public companies is that I then
took my my prototypes and I showed the
step from step one to start step 10 and
when the buyer got to step ten guess
what it was it was the product in
package manufactured I go that's the
manufactured toy that's what it's going
to look like in your store and they
couldn't believe it that it was like
whoa that looks just like your prototype
yes that's what I've been saying right
but the point of a prototype right but
everybody else had been using a
prototype the other way yeah to sucker
them in until eventually they got to the
point that like hey if McFarland shows
you something that's actually what it's
going to look like and they started
buying into that maybe there was a
quality component to these products that
were coming in I didn't have any big
Brands right so I had to beat them with
pricing and quality because how how else
am I going to survive next to Star Wars
and Transformers and GI Joe and Marvel I
can't and what year is this roughly
would you say we started the toy company
in 94 and so literally from the first
time we hit the ground running okay
here's the thing that's interesting is
that if you look at the first wave of
toys first two three four waves of toys
I put out they were winning Awards and
people were going oh my God Todd look at
you you're just you've upgraded the
whole industry and if you look at those
toys they're laughable compared to my
standards today they are laughable and
even yet back then just that upgrade put
me on the map and here's the other thing
too nobody else was doing what I was
doing in terms of quality in terms of
the pricing that went with it and and
then in terms of brand selection so
here's the thing about big big
corporations their blessing and their
curse is their size
right they have more people more money
more everything they can squish you at
every moment but because of that giant
enormous size they don't move fast and
if you can just be quick and Nimble with
your business I never once said I'm
going to slay the giant that's never the
question Todd you know how do you take
down Hasbro no no no no you're asking
the question in Reverse not how do I
take down Hasbro Mattel their billion
dollar Empires the question is how do
billion dollar empires not squish me I
am a gnat how can they not kill me and
the answer is because why why would
Hasbro Mattel or any other public
company want me to have one foot of
space in Walmart that's their territory
that's their money yeah and and so the
question is why can't they kill me and
the answer is because when you're big
and you're a giant and you're a sloth
and I'm a mosquito and I'm biting you on
your right arm by the time you
contemplate slapping that mosquito
you're so slow with your movement
that by time you slap your arm I'm on
the other side I'm on the other side
they can't move quick enough Tim and
that's their weakness and once I exploit
their weakness and the weakness and toys
was they will never do anything outside
their comfort zone what does that mean
they'll never make Freddy Krueger
they'll never make the Terminator toy
they'll never make the Matrix they'll
never make essentially R-rated toys and
I felt that there was a need that you
could sell toys to adults you just have
to put it in the right content I can
sell a toy to my mom I just have to make
it look like Tom Jones and she'll buy it
because she loves Tom Jones so if you
put it in the right brand then there's
an audience that's out there and now we
call it geekdom and and I was the only
guy doing it so everything I was doing
was like oh my gosh oh my god there are
now dozens of people and companies that
do what I do so I'm not nearly as unique
anymore but back then I was the
Trailblazer so let's talk about 1994 the
reason I asked about that timing
ties into where you were going
a handful of minutes ago with respect to
how do you sell these toys right how do
you get the sell through once you get
toys placed store-wide in say Toys R Us
and 1994 is relevant because I was
thinking how would you have any direct
fan
Outreach to drive sales Because the
Internet because now you have social you
have email even email was really nascent
in terms of mainstream adoption in 1994.
so a couple of questions
and you can tackle them in any any order
one is
how on Earth do you actually ensure
these toys sell once you get them at
retail the second is
related to the comment you made about so
and so
huge toy company owning real estate in a
given retail store or chain and I know
that it's fairly common at retail for
people to pay for placement so they have
they pay extra they pay the retailer for
end caps they own the first say 20 feet
of a store I'm making up this example
but like Coca-Cola boom they own the
first you know 20 feet deep at a B and C
retailers and you you literally cannot
invade that territory it's just not
possible it's been paid for it's this is
true in publishing as well with books
and and so on like they're all these
they might call them co-marketing fees
they might call them placement fees
they're all sorts of crazy crazy uh
incentives that make it hard for a
smaller company to break in so one is
how on Earth do you sell these toys when
you have them placed at retail but then
maybe the precursor to that is how do
you even get the placement
can you afford
maybe this doesn't exist in toys but
like do you have to pay those placement
fees in which case like how do you pay
for it there are iterations of what
you're talking about but not quite what
you're saying
I think this is closer to what the
reality is is the stores have let's say
they have a run of 100 feet let's say
that again I'm in the boys toy action
figure aisle let's just keep that let's
aisle five let's call it aisle five
aisle five is a hundred feet long
they I think the buyers for the most
part go I'm gonna dedicate eighty
percent of that 85 percent of that to
the Big Brand and we all know what they
are because we see
you know
foot upon foot upon foot of these Brands
and they rotate them out depending on
what the movies are and what's hot in
the Zeitgeist they go okay 85 that's
going to be given to the thing that's
going to be in every company's I don't
care whether you're Kmart Walmart Amazon
everybody's gonna have it then there's
the 15 left and the 15 is ah this is
where you know
just in case we're missing something
just to give us a little bit of
diversity
just so that we can have you know sort
of hedge our bet at the roulette table a
little bit and that was the space that I
needed to get into I needed to figure
out could I Rise and get in to the sales
that were worthy of that
15 and so to your first question how did
I get people to know and buy the Spawn
toys at the beginning I didn't in all
honesty the internet I know this seems
foreign to people was literally just in
its infancy and so that wasn't the
gameplay
the only play was
value quality
and put it together
and hopefully people would notice it
because the the upside of making toys
and action figures is
the packaging is see-through so you
actually get to see what you're buying
there's no fake photo and then you take
it home and you go man that didn't look
that good right
what you see is is what you get and I
think that my toys just quickly passed
the eye test
to a lot of people and and again
remember I was coming off you know
setting records with Spider-Man and then
we quickly went to do the comic books
with spawn so there was a big fan base
that was there
and they went oh my gosh Todd's gonna do
some toy so they jumped on very quickly
and and as you know in any business
you're only as good as sort of your last
set of sales right it doesn't matter
what you have today
is they just look at the data of your
last ones and so once the first
series came out and did really well and
then the second one continued because I
got to put some characters in it it just
I don't know it just and then the
internet started to become
a little bit relevant and we were
getting traffic even on our our own
website that was phenomenal I was
getting pulled into Hollywood people
going Todd how are you getting that much
traffic I mean big studios asking me how
I was getting the traffic that they
weren't getting as a studio so at some
point the Geeks just find you Tim and
you just
I would like to say that I knew what I
was doing all this time and that somehow
I'm a savant it's not it's not true you
just you try your darndest and
sometimes that 30-foot shot Banks into
the bucket and you and you scored the
three points and you go wow I can't say
I can replicate it
but what you do is once you have
momentum
can you keep momentum it's like a good
disc jockey the good disc jockey keep
people on the floor dancing the bad ones
figure out how to put on a song that
everybody walks off right I need to
basically keep the momentum going and
finding places here's where I kept the
momentum we started selling places like
Virgin records and Tower Records and KB
Toys and and hot topics and we were
going to what I was said earlier
non-traditional places and they were
buying lots and lots of toys you know
why because I was making like crazy
R-rated at times gory toys and then all
they cared about was the one magic
sentence
Walmart's not buying this boom we'll
take it because now they don't have to
compete because if you go into
competition with the big boys everybody
has the same product you're just going
to get into a pricing war and they want
a product that the big boys didn't have
and back then I could make anything up
in my head put it in the plastic and I
had hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of sales waiting for these guys who
didn't want to compete with the big boys
unfortunately the world changes and
babbages and Virgin records and KB these
companies don't even exist anymore right
so there was a consolidation and and
some of the fun that we were having at
the beginning is no longer sort of
available to us
so momentum you strike me as someone
who's a very good
creative and business DJ
to push the metaphor uh which I like
you mentioned the four pillars games TV
movies toys it seems like toys came in
one of the earlier chapters in terms of
setting that pillar of the foundation
where did
whether it's music
TV directing any of those other elements
come into the picture I'm gonna get to
that let me just go back to toys and
tell one more quick story yes please
so there's another story that people to
this day scratched their head on and it
was in 1998 Mark Maguire if you're a
baseball fan Mark Maguire and Sammy Sosa
were going for the Home Run title yep
and at the end of the season Mark
Maguire hit 70 home runs the prior
record was 61 home runs by Roger Maris a
Sammy Sosa hit 66 that year okay why is
that relevant because for a couple years
I had been I'd start my toy company in
1994 and I'm I'm an athlete and that's
like again stick to what you know I know
Sport and I was trying to make sports
toys and I couldn't make sports toys why
I couldn't even get a meeting because
I'm a nobody who's taken the NHL Major
League Baseball the NBA NHL why would
anybody let me in their front door they
wouldn't and so you have to figure out
back doors and Alternatives so here is
the play and again I from one
perspective it seems like the dumbest
thing that a human being can do I'll
give you what I was doing during that
play anyways the 70 McGuire ball the
last ball hit that was the record goes
up for an auction in Madison Square
Garden I'm the anonymous bidder anyways
nobody's ever spent more than three
hundred thousand four hundred thousand
dollars on any baseball paraphernalia at
the end of the auction I end up winning
the 70 ball and it cost me three million
dollars ten times what the previous
record was streaming million dollars now
you can say and I understand this
perspective why would any
any
human being with a brain spend three
million dollars for a three dollar
baseball why would they do that
especially given a couple years later
Barry Bonds broke the record oh by the
way I had to go buy that ball too
but I bought the 70 ball here's what the
70 ball did and it seems like the
stupidest thing right three million
dollars for baseball it's stupid you
never get your money back out of it it
depends on how you're looking at it
here's how I was looking at it
I knew that spending and getting that
ball would get me headlined right so so
instantly it was a national story and I
was on lots of talk radio shows and TV
shows and everything I mean I I
canvassed the planet and do you know how
much money it would cost to get that
attention by buying ads in any of those
areas it would cost you way more than
three million but let's put that to the
side
here's what it did those headlines then
got seen by all the sports leagues and
the unions and when I phoned the next
time and said hey I'm Tom McFarland I
don't know maybe you heard me I bought
the McGuire Ball but I just like talk to
you I'm also in the toy business they
let me in the door and I got to have a
conversation with them in short order I
ended up having the license for baseball
football basketball and hockey I did it
for 13 years I can tell you ladies and
gentlemen I made more than three million
dollars in profits on those toys
multiple times
over those 13 years so at some point you
have to put up an ante on the table to
play the big game with the big boys in
poker and my auntie unfortunately was a
three million dollar baseball so that
they took that as saying which just so
everybody knows it was every red scent I
had and then some I had to beg more and
steal to pay for it then what ended up
happening that people see those
headlines and they go oh if he's got
three million dollars to wipe his ass on
the baseball he must be successful he
must have a lot of money he bring the
successful guy into the room and I got
the four licenses and it was there one
last comment on it why do you care that
I spent three million on a baseball
because
for me I've made it over multiple times
and anytime I do any interview because
I'm now the expert just so everybody
knows guess how many interviews I did
when Aaron judge this year was going to
do a ball people were asking me how much
the ball is worth I'm now an expert
because I spend an ungodly amount on one
ball I become an expert this is how
silly all this is I get to amortize that
three million dollars once again that's
sitting there but if I don't spend that
money and I don't get there I don't get
to the table then my company never does
any of it
so here's why this is one of the reasons
Tim I can't be I can't be public
because you can't play that game I can't
go to the shareholders into the board
and the chairman of the board and say
hey I've got this gut feeling that if I
do this one thing I think it will pay
off if you can't categorize it on a
spreadsheet in rows and columns and tell
them what it's going to equate to in
terms of capital money and profit
margins in 90 days you're going to get
shot down and this is why I can't go
public and let me tell you when my toy
companies were flying did Wall Street
come and knock on my door of course they
did Tim of course they did but it was I
horrified them to the point that I
become a bit of a talking
moment because I've run into them years
later they would come and here's what I
found with Wall Street Todd we're going
to give you x amount of dollars and
we're going to buy your company
okay that's cool but I'm still in
control well no no no no at that money
that amount of money you're not in
control what
I Gotta Give Up control of my company
for what your money I already got money
I don't need any of the money so they're
like okay and then here's where Wall
Street is literally a one trick pony
okay doc we won't give you x amount of
money
we see that you're a little stubborn
we'll give you 2X
no no no okay so but if you give me
twice the money do I have control no
whoa that's a problem Todd last time
we'll give you three x of money
guys let me let me now Define what money
is to me right
here's the word I'm Canadian so maybe
you guys in America do a little bit
differently right so my dad taught me a
word it's called useless right and
here's what useless is is when you have
something and you don't use it right so
do you know that I have money in the
bank right now which basically means I'm
not using it so it's kind of useless to
me because I'm not using it because it's
just sitting in a bank doing nothing
right
do you know the reaction to people from
Wall Street when you called their one
product useless do you know how
horrifying it is that they're just going
what did you just call them what did you
just call money right and eventually
they stopped coming and then I remember
I was at a party years later and I
introduced myself and then they went
Todd McFly why do I know that name and
it was somebody I'd never met before and
I'm like oh you're the guy that does it
like money right it was it was and and
look at let me tell you and I've told
everybody look at guys I'm not a saint
I'm not saying I can be bought we all
have a price the price though that I
needed that day was that they would give
me enough money that I would then give
up control of the company but have so
much money I could then buy it back at a
discount fire all of them and I'd still
have a profit and I'd have my company
back but nobody's ever given me that
deal so I so I've just never sold the
company and they've stopped saying Todd
I'm just a Madman so anyways over to
Hollywood now well before we get to
Hollywood I want to do a deep dive on
the madman part so you mentioned that
this 3 million was basically all the
money you had and then some yeah you
strike me as a risk taker but you strike
me as a calculated risk taker you don't
give me the impression of being Reckless
right some people could say well if you
say yes to Toys R Us and you haven't
even figured out manufacturing that's
reckless but it's not Reckless because
what's the downside you can't figure it
out and you're like sorry pal I can't
make it work the downside's actually
really really limited for you three
million bucks different story so
given that the NHL and NBA and so on
hadn't returned your phone calls up to
that point what gave you the confidence
or how did you do the calculus did you
have enough safety net that you were
like ah this could suck for a year or
two if they don't actually open up to me
how did you think about this what was
the reasoning going into it so there's
two things that I thought were going
again keeping the momentum going in my
favor one I had the data of all the toys
that I was doing with spawn right and
spawn at that point it hit a point where
consecutive series that were coming out
I think we got all the way up to 36 was
the second longest running streak of
series of toys other than I think
Transformers even it was even longer
than Star Wars Star Wars had gone quiet
and gone dark for a while so again there
was a little bit of that I planted one
small seed before I made the crazy play
in the in the small seed was I was able
to get to the players union of the NHL
right because of the four major sports
most people will say especially in terms
of Revenue that the NHL is like the
fourth one the stepchild if you will and
so I didn't go to the league because I
knew I couldn't get there I went to the
union and just so you know if you ever
make any sports to stories of any
current players you must have two
license you have to license the union so
you can get the players and their
likeness and then you have to get a
contract from the league so that you can
get basically their uniforms and their
logos and then you have to glue the two
together and you have a double royalty
they have to pay it's not the best model
but it if you want to do it that's how
it works so I went to
the NHL players union which was like
nobody ever gives us any money because
they just sell jerseys and stuff with
logos everything's a logo logo logos on
the hat and I said I'm gonna make toys
of your players but unfortunately I
can't put their uniforms on them because
I don't have an NHL I'm gonna have to do
generic uniforms right
and they want yeah sure we'll take money
so I had in my back pocket one small
seat I had the union of the NHL so that
later once I spent the money on the
McGuire ball and and I was hoping I
would get a meeting then I could go in
there and say one of the first meetings
I took was with the NHL per se and I
just pulled out my toys and I go guys
look at these toys aren't they cool they
look just like pavalberry and Mario
Lemieux and Wayne Gretzky look at him
these are super awesome right here's the
thing notice that I don't get to use
your uniform
and at that point I had sort of had a
conversation with them and they were
threatening to sue me because they said
that my generic uniforms were looking
like theirs right I I think I even done
some McGuire generic meguires too
and I'd even at that point then went to
the NFL
the union and I go hey I've got the
baseball and I've now got the hockey
like again it all tumbled and so I was
then able to go into rooms I remember
this these odd conversations you have
Tim that are just
I just want to hit my head against walls
but whatever
I'm in a room with the NHL and there's
like six lawyers there's always lawyers
and they're threatening they're
threatening to sue me because I'm doing
like a sort of a generic a generic
uniform on one of the players that I had
there and they're going we're going to
sue you
you cannot do these toys and I'm like oh
yeah
you shoot my ass you chew my ass because
here's how it works here's how it works
and you guys aren't even smart enough to
know how this works number one you're
sitting here right now across this table
telling me you own everything good sue
me and if you win you don't get a
[ __ ] ounce of upgrade you say you got
a hundred percent at the end the best
you can hope for is a hundred percent go
ahead and do it but if you pay attention
and you do a little bit of research on
me you're pulling the wrong tiger's tail
right because I'll do this because
here's the thing if we go to court and
you find out that you don't have a
hundred percent and I'm betting you
don't that not only do I get a piece of
that hundred percent it is gonna
basically be a story for every human
being on this planet they can now go
against you so you got two choices you
can either go to court and say that
somehow you own reddish colors and
bluish colors if you want to make that
argument be my guest or
what I'm saying I've got to check for a
half a million dollars here I'd like to
shove down your throat to give me your
[ __ ] logos I don't know sue me and
potentially lose 100 or take a half a
million dollars this seems like my
six-year-old could figure out what this
thing is eventually they took the half a
million bucks right so what are you
talking about like of course they did of
course they did right it's like stop it
and sadly I had to sort of play the same
conversation with everybody when I had
the NFL and I'm like I'm doing your
players the question is do you want any
of the cash it's that I mean at some
point forget the art and forget anything
else just get down to the core of it do
you want any of this money I'm about to
make the answer is yes or no and if you
don't find oh by the way I thought you
were in the Commerce business because
you're a public company but you guys go
ahead and do what you want to do I it is
amazing how many times I've had to try
and shove money down people's throats
but anyways that's that's Corporate
America they do they do their thing I do
mine
so doing your thing
let's hop across some lily pads and uh
touch on whichever you want to touch on
next the
music TV movies how do any of these
other elements I know you've mentioned
games but
which of these elements enter the
picture
let's talk about TV first right so again
go back to the release of the Spawn
comic book after we leave Marvel the
group of us leave Marvel my character
spawn is comes out bam shoots to the top
of the charts and for months and months
even maybe a couple years it was a
number one selling book so it was at the
top of the chart so like I said phone
calls were constantly coming I get the
phone call and on the other line is HBO
right legit at that point I mean when
you talk about they're still legit right
but they were one of the big sort of
companies out there and I and I go oh
cool and they said hey we want to do
some animation
and I knew like animation is like
Saturday morning cartoons right and a
couple of my my partners at Image Comics
had sold and we're gonna get Saturday
morning cartoons which they did spawn
again a guy from The Penthouse just
wasn't what I wanted and so I remember
and I don't say this as a joke I said as
and I'll tell you why I asked this one
question I go no hey guys it's cool I
appreciate your enthusiasm let me let me
ask you just one question I just have
one question for you can I say [ __ ]
in my show
and and it wasn't meant to be a joke it
was just
and they paused
and then they said
yeah yeah probably like why not right
and that was all I needed to hear not
that I wanted to use that word Tim not
that I wanted to do and show naked women
or anything I just thought that if they
were willing to basically say yes to
that then I could basically that I had a
wide Lane of creativity yeah and the
reason I needed a wide Lane because
my character lives in a dark serious
world and I'm gonna have corrupt
policemen and I'm gonna have Mafia
people and I'm gonna have criminals I'm
gonna have drug addict and these people
don't talk politely right when they get
mad you have to be able to go into like
watching an R-rated movie you have to be
able to have a certain dialogue for your
characters that matches who they are
right and so I just needed to if the
moment came I needed to be able to do
that and have the creative freedom to do
it so when they said yeah sure then I
was like cool
then let's do it oh one more thing
I know nothing about animation never
spent a second on it but I got to be in
charge
so you guys go and have that talk and do
what you got to do and they came back
and said yeah yeah you can you can be a
charge but we're gonna put some good
people on your flanks which they did and
we went in there and so I was
working on HBO animation at this time
Tim
HBO had started an animation Division I
think there was five maybe six shows
going on of which spawn Was Won very
quickly
the other five failed and I was sort of
the Lone Wolf by the end of it but
when we first came out
I was in the room now with this group of
people that had amassed for to make an
animated show
who collectively probably had
600 years of experience
and here's the frustrating thing that
I've run into over and over and over in
my life
the bark being way better than the bite
and so artists would go yeah all these
all these creative people all these
people worked on animation man if we
could only do it our way man these
people these executive they don't know
anything yeah I've heard that over and
over and over and we finally get to a
point where literally we can almost do
anything and guess what a lot of them
did they just went back to status quo
they just went back to status quo and so
being the dumbest guy in the room I used
to ask these questions there's there's
really
any question there's a legitimate answer
why you can't do it it's usually time or
money
oh you can do it but it's going to cost
more money I can't do that I have a
budget
no it doesn't cost any more money but
it's going to take twice as long ah we
don't have the luxury of the deadline so
so that's it I and I understand so I
would constantly be asking these
questions can we do this no why because
of this okay but every now and then
being the dumb guy in the room
I didn't know where the guard rails were
so I'd ask a question and then you get
the moment Tim which is you ask a
question and you've got you know 50
people in a room and I go if we do this
we'll cause this any more time or or
money
I mean a little bit of effort maybe but
about the same and then you get you get
to me the golden moment pregnant pause
silent
so there was nobody in the room with 600
years experience saying no we can't do
that no we can't do that dot and I went
so you're saying that
it won't take more time no and it won't
cost more money no so why don't we do it
well that's not how we do it here no no
I understand that's not how we do it I'm
not asking that question I'm saying
we'll take more time or money you're
saying no why are we figuring out how to
self edit ourselves self Center
ourselves when nobody else is this is a
crime why are we putting guardrails on
ourselves we should be smashing up
against the walls until the executives
upstairs go whoa guys whoa whoa whoa
pull it back right that's what we should
be doing but when you've had a dog that
has been in a small backyard for so long
it gets comfortable that the moment you
throw the doors open to the to the Wild
farmlands and you go run rover go it was
amazing how many creative people
sat down instead of running because
that's all they knew they knew one way
to do animation and then the one way to
draw it and then into one way to
storytell and then you knew one way and
one way and one way and one way and
here's the frustration
by the end of the three years we were
butting heads because they all thought I
was the crazy guy whatever else we won
Emmys on that
show and I remember being up on the
stage holding and getting my Emmy and
behind me was 15 of these people most of
them I was constantly having to
basically drag them
into some of these decisions and they
were all holding an Emmy in their hands
too and with a big smile and I was like
going oh my God here you are so happy
you got an Emmy in your hand and it's be
and you were resistant to almost
everything that as the reason why we're
up on this stage today right it was I it
bugged me that I was putting that award
in their hands because they were not
willing participants
for the ride but the reason we ended up
getting canceled wasn't because people
weren't watching it it was because
and this is again just the way of the
world right names Todd only rhymes with
God I don't get to control any of this
and it was that they had five shows
remember I said they started an
animation show right and every time a
show got canceled one of the animations
got canceled they just put all the costs
on the existing show
and eventually all of them failed except
for me and I remember them calling me in
saying Todd we gotta we've got to stop
the animation I go why to go it's
getting too expensive and I went
expensive you haven't given me one red
Cent more than you did the first year
I'm I'm working on the exact same budget
it's like Yeah well yeah and then I
found out I was covering all the other
overhead that had basically
failed accrued and so they put that on
my budget and then they have to get so
many eyeballs per dollar and somehow
they had put all that money that accrued
onto mine and it fell under their
threshold and whatever Matrix they used
and they'd never go public with any but
it was like that was it I was like we
were doing the exact same job winning
Emmys doing exactly what we were doing
but now all of a sudden they have to let
us go because somehow the math didn't
work for them so question for you about
that it's it seems like and I know this
is simplifying but you've had this
incredible bull run with
Spider-Man image toys and then you have
this television experience which is
super challenging doesn't end the way
probably would have liked it to end well
run Emmys so I'll take that up great
that leads into my question which is
are you glad you had that experience or
would you have
removed it and replaced it with
something else how did you contend with
that yourself did you feel good about it
at the end yeah sure proud of it yeah
okay this is easy there's only one human
being I have dominion over
me period yeah I don't my wife I love
her I've been with her for over 40 years
like I like I don't even control her
right and she's the closest person that
I have in the world so
okay I don't I don't worry it's I mean
it can be exhausting at times trying to
drag people to the water but you can't
make the horse drink at times so at some
point I just go guys you do your thing
I do my thing and we'll just figure it
out I do not stand by water coolers and
complain about bosses I quit jobs and
start my own companies
as a creative person if I'm going to
complain about how the business works
then I will then go and become my own
businessman I consider myself Tim to be
bilingual
I have learned the language of business
I am first and foremost a fluent speaker
in art that is my native tongue but I
have learned business to the point where
I can now go into a meeting with
Executives or Bankers or government
people or whatever and sound like a CEO
who happens to be a pretty good artist I
can convince them that I'm that guy that
they go oh okay he just the art is sort
of like he just does it on the side
because if I'm going to
I've got two choices I either let people
with experience do the business side of
it and have full trust in them and
knowledge and what they're doing so I
know that I can trust them or I just
figure it out myself my personality
didn't allow me to put it in the hands
of others if I'm going to fail I want to
fail on my own merits and so I just
learned business did it take away from
the art of course it did every time I'm
in one of these dumb meetings for an
hour I am acutely aware that I am not
creating and everything in my world
business-wise is a byproduct of me doing
some kind of creating it's a Fallout of
my me creating and when I'm not creating
I don't think I'm bringing the most
value to my company
I need I need to be an artist as much as
possible but I also need to be able to
sing
and tell the story of what we do
for the company so that we can get past
the nose and and because I can be very
stubborn of going well before you say no
let me just download you with the
reality of what you're walking away from
and see at the beginning it was all Bs
let me just tell you it was it was BS
but as the years have gone by there's
hardcore data now right Tim let me just
again go back a little bit last year
I don't even pay attention to the last
year there's the equivalent of the
Nielsen ratings in toys and they
literally count when something gets
scanned at the big Superstores all the
it goes into a database so we're not
talking about you're the most popular
you got the coolest toy Todd those are
different Awards this is data based on
sales last year
our line of DC Multiverse toys I don't
even have them I don't I don't even have
the master license of DC Multiverse I
have a fraction of it I have the
collective little sliver of it and our
sliver
of that outsold not only the master toy
license of that but it outsold
everything Marvel and everything Star
Wars it was the number one selling line
in America and Canada my company
literally that is a handful of people
sold more toys in action figure lines
than Hasbro Mattel Playmates Spin Master
all these public companies right and the
question is either I'm and my people are
geniuses or they're not getting full
value for whatever infrastructure they
did I think the answer lies somewhere in
between right how is it that I can take
on Fortune 500 companies last year I had
the number one selling comic book
doesn't want to sound comic book
Marvel's owned by Disney DC Comics is
owned by Warner Brothers 18 T Warner
Brothers Discovery whatever it is this
week
that's there those are billion dollar
Empires and my comic book division is
four people how do four people take on
billion dollar Empires and beat them at
times at their own game I don't know I
don't know it's it's a curiosity why
aren't they selling more I don't know go
ask them I'm just doing my gig but it's
doable and and I'm hoping that the story
of a guy like me should be hopefully to
some people somewhat inspirational
because every time I read a story where
David took on Goliath and didn't get
killed didn't slay the giant just didn't
get killed himself right those should be
encouraging of that yes you too can go
against these guys and succeed and
here's the thing as long as your company
is the right size with the right
overhead you can make a profit
you can make ten thousand dollars a
month and make a profit as long as your
overhead is less than ten thousand or
you can make a hundred million a year
and lose money
because your overhead is over a hundred
million you just have to right size your
company and you can make money don't
worry about being rich just go I make
thirty thousand as long as we spend 25
we're making five grand a month it's a
living it's a living cool and you're
having fun doing it
two questions related to all of this
that the first is
we're going to bounce around
chronologically but
how do you protect or create the time
for
creativity and making right so if we
think about it as making versus managing
so the making is the creative stuff the
managing is all the meetings all of the
CEO stuff
I would have to imagine there have been
times where you've looked at your
calendar after a hard week and you're
like for [ __ ] sake I've spent 90 plus
maybe 100 of my time this week managing
stuff
how have you
been able to block out or protect the
time to create have you thought about
that as as someone who has all these
different business ventures now
it's the Eternal question we all
struggle with how do we balance our life
we all ask that both on the personal in
the work we're always going how how does
this work
I through
failures Tim
found that I was a five ball juggler
right
and here's what that means
that I don't care who you are I don't
care if you're the best juggler in Vegas
and you're with Cirque du Soleil and you
can juggle 25 balls even that person if
you go one ball more than they're
capable of guess what happens
all the balls fall every ball you're
juggling hits the floor and it's a mess
and so I unfortunately
let the balls drop at times that I was
acutely aware that I was doing a
disservice to certain areas and I
learned that I was a five ball jungler
and here's what that means for me it
means that I'm always constantly
juggling Fireballs but if another
opportunity comes along and I get
excited about it and it makes sense both
from an artistic and from a business CEO
level I must put one of the five balls I
am currently juggling down
or put it in the hands of others
and give them full trust to do what they
need to do before I pick up that new
opportunity so that I'm constantly at
five and don't extend myself
and so it was a lesson hard learned over
the years and what that also meant was
Todd
you can't do all the artwork yourself so
you're going to have to become a good
scout and you're going to have to find
talent and at some point on a good day I
feel that I am Phil Jackson when he was
coaching the Chicago Bulls I think maybe
not his conversation went something like
this
Michael Jordan Scottie Pippen and I
don't even know what the name is of the
rest of your dudes
could you guys just go over there or not
your job is could you put that ball in
that bucket oh
by the way
if you have any questions to that
in-depth analysis I just gave you I'll
be over here in my three-piece suit with
my clipboard and you just come over and
ask me a question and Phil Jackson was
smart enough to find the proper talent
and put it in the proper place so that
the end of that run
not only did Michael Jordan have six
championship rings so did Phil and you
know many buckets Phil made during that
time zero he was just smart enough to
know to put Michael and the crew out
there in the right iterations and so
there are times where you have to just
go Todd you can't build this all
yourself there are some things that make
sense for me being the lead and or even
isolating myself artistically there are
plenty of other things we do making toys
making comic book making movies making
video games all of it that's a
collective team and I actually sort of
enjoy being with the collective team
because if I can find my Michael
Jordan's and my Scottie Pippins
and I'm in a meeting and they show me
their skill
artistically or with ideas or how to
promote or how to sell or Market
whatever in any field in any sort of
skill set
and I feel like I'm the dumbest guy in
the room those are great days for me Tim
because I sit there and go oh my gosh I
wouldn't have even thought of that I
can't even do it to that skill set thank
God they work for me right and I just
sit there and go hmm and if I really
want to make it look like that I'm sort
of more important that I am I I'll say
something like interesting I'll take it
under revisement and get back to
everybody tomorrow right we're inside
I'm going holy [ __ ] this is awesome I
just hope they don't quit and start
their own company and compete against me
because they're super awesome and so
that's it you have to find talent and
Coach them along the way I'm just a
coach I just I feel like I'm a coach now
hearkening back to what you said about
last year and toy sales so the example
you gave was DC so we're not talking
about Freddy Krueger we're talking about
DC so it's not the R rated Advantage
presumably these are at Large
retailers oh yeah so you no longer have
the
Hot Topic Advantage how are you
competing so effectively and I would
imagine also the people have emulated
and tried to copy the Style by adding
more detail and trying to compete I
assume that maybe that's an incorrect
assumption but how are you guys still
competing so effectively and selling
certainly as multiple of your head
counts so much more than these other
guys
brand matters
so I'd been making toys for 25 years
that I said every day of my life
I can sell Star Wars just give me the
contract what are you talking about it's
Star Wars right what are you talking
about Star Wars but you know come I
don't sell a lot of Spider-Man because I
don't have the contract and eventually
I'd walk around toy fair and it seemed
like everybody had a piece of Marvel
everybody had a piece of Star Wars in
the DC Comics and except for me I don't
know why I was the only guy right but
somehow we ended up doing a deal Warner
Brothers walking away from Mattel they
had given Mattel both the master toy
license and the collective sliver
I guess it didn't what is the difference
between the master toy and the
collective I guess I'm not sure what the
difference is between those two would
you mind just explaining that those
definitions are in our internal
definitions for every corporation they
Define them differently but essentially
a master toy license means that you
basically not only get to do action
figures but you get to do the Nerf gun
versions of them and you get to do the
Hot Wheels with the logos on it you
basically you can be you can do puzzles
you're in the entire store if you want
to be you've got all the aisles I'm in
aisle five boys action figure all right
I always said no I don't want to
diversify I want to just be the king of
aisle five if I could that's it like
just focus don't get don't get lost in
all the other aisles just be good at one
aisle you know I'd rather be a master of
one than the Jack of all trade So
eventually we ended up couple years back
getting after decades to try finally we
got the license for the DC Multiverse
let me tell you really what the big
piece of that was I had the word Batman
and Superman on my toy right like what
are you talking about those are Global
Brands right so I've always told people
look it and you and I have discussed it
here if you do a quality product
at a fair price and do a little bit of
marketing and build a better mousetrap
you can you can survive how do I know
I've done it for 25 27 years prior
but I always had a butt to it but if you
ever give me a triple A brand on top of
that on top of that mythology
[ __ ] get out of the way right what do
you talk about because now I'm going to
give them price and quality and a name
that everybody knows I've been saying
that for years and guess what they
finally give me one of the big Brands
and guess what we outsold all of them
boom right now here's one of the things
also that mattered
big companies and this is their job I'm
not saying it's good bad I'm just saying
this is their job is to maximize value
for the shareholders every 90 days how
do you do that you just make as much
money as you can how do you make as much
money as you can you figure out how to
cut Corners right until one of the ways
you cut Corners in our trade of toys is
that you reuse the same pieces right
Lego does the same thing I mean I don't
care how ambitious it that whatever it
is you're buying there's still certain
blocks I mean the colors may be
different but there are still certain
blocks that are Universal in every one
of their builds and then they put the
unique pieces that will make it into the
shape they need but there's still a
portion of the ReUse of blocks that have
been used for decades because that's
their formula cool it works for them
toys are sort of the same that they go
ah you know we'll do a generic body and
we won't make anything unique about it
and then that way we can paint it with a
bat symbol on it or a s or a Flash and
it all sort of works and we don't have
to cut any more mold we don't have to
cut any more steel why because that's
money
and we don't have to do all those things
so
early on
when I was given the people Warner
Brothers are lineups
and we were talking to them like I want
to make this character and there let's
talk about this and then they go on we
can't really make that character and I
go wine and go well you know it doesn't
really share the same look as any other
character and I want no no I know that
no we're good I'll just you know we'll
cut some new mold and when they found
out that I was willing to make new molds
for specifically for one character
they were blown away by that because
they've been dealing with the big boys
and they were going to Jose so you're
going to do five new characters and make
five new sets of molds uh-huh
and that's okay with you
yeah I've been doing it for years
wow and here's why that mattered Tim
because it allowed me now for the very
first time to make characters that
nobody had made prior to that people
have been making Superman and Batman and
Wonder Woman toys for decades of course
they had but some of the other
iterations of the those characters and
or B characters or C characters that
look super cool I don't care if you even
know their name in plastic they look
super cool on the Shelf I was able to
make them and then I think there was a
big enough audience and geeked them that
came by and went oh my goodness nobody's
ever made that character or that
character or that character or that
character and they were able to get like
literally the rookie cards he wasn't
sort of trading card they're getting the
rookie cards of all these characters
that nobody had ever made before and I
think it mattered I think it mattered
that I was doing something different
than what the big boys did
death that makes sense all right I'm
glad I asked thank you for answering
so where to from there so or I should
say not really from there because these
are all parallel lines in a sense right
the comic books are going the toys are
going they each create an opportunity so
again let's talk about music videos you
mentioned that how do you get to music
videos right I don't even read music I
can't read it look at music and I've got
a Grammy how's that possible Right some
dumbass kid who doesn't know anything
about Music's Got a Grammy
it bothers my wife she's a very good
pianist right it bugs her I got one so
don't say it out loud if you come to
dinner so here's how you get there you
just find the back door
they're always going to block the front
door status quo is going to always get
put in front of you you find the back
door here's the back door
out of the blue we're doing the HBO
animation right it's doing pretty well
and again a winning couple Emmys and
then out of the blue I don't know why go
go ask him out of the blue I get a phone
call from Eddie Vetter Eddie Vedder is
the lead singer of Pearl Jam and Eddie
then says hey Todd Eddie hey Eddie how
are you doing bud
here's what we want to do Todd the
record label is bugging us to do a music
video
we hate music videos and we don't want
to be in it which is sort of a cool
thing that it's a pardon you don't want
to be in your own music video no and
we've been putting them off and putting
them off but they keep bugging us so now
we're at the point where I've I figured
it out Todd I just I've been watching
this spawn animation on TV
we can do it animate it let's just do it
animate it and then we don't have to be
in it and I was like okay cool in terms
you want to help us with it I'm like
yeah sure cool what's the gig and then
he sort of gave the song it was called
do the evolution
and I go towards it about he goes oh
it's about all time space and dimension
but you got to do it in three and a half
minutes
I go okay I think we can pick them up
with some creative things on it and then
Eddie went away and he goes here I'll
send you something here in a couple days
just to sort of give you the vibe and so
a couple days later I received in the
mail from Eddie
this tape and I play it and he's taking
a couple of episodes of Spawn and edited
them to go with his music of the song
that we were talking about do the
evolution that must have been surreal I
wish I had that tape I don't know what I
did with this tape and so I get on the
phone and it was really good I got to
tell you Tim it was really good and I
get on the phone I go
I said hey Eddie this is I got it I
understand what you want to do okay
whatever we'll come up with that who
edited this thing this is super cool and
he says oh that was me
you you edited this video you have the
big editing machine was called an avid
you have an avid at home yeah I have an
avid so wow Eddie you're confusing me a
bit so rock and rollers when they're
done off stage go home relax by doing
Avid editing this is what like it
doesn't make any sense to me right but
he's like yeah I just sort of like it
and it's just sort of therapeutic and
I'm like cool so we end up doing the
video and doing the the animation for it
it ends up getting nominated for a
Grammy which again so it was my first
foray in the music I went what you just
you go into music and you get nominated
for a Grammy that was easy should have
done this earlier we launched the
Madonna that year
but Eddie we're going to edit and Eddie
says hey is there any way I can come to
California and edit with you
Eddie it's your video you can do
whatever you want sugar heck so he sat
with us in the three days that we were
there editing and he and he's really
smart I mean really he had a lot of good
stuff hey what if you did this what if
you cut this down and you did this and
whatever and he's talking the language
right so it was really good the Side
Story of that three days was
he came with a briefcase
the first day and he's you know Eddie
I'll dress in black but he had a
briefcase what I thought was like sort
of formal
if you put the briefcase down next to us
and then we worked all day and we did
the editing and then he left
and then the next day he came
dressed just like you know grunge yeti
cool and he had his briefcase again and
he put it right down next to us never
touched it the whole day again and he
left and then on the third day he came
same thing but at some point I just want
hey Eddie I don't mean to pry but
why do you keep bringing that
briefcase with you every day doesn't
seem like you do anything with it and
then he goes oh my gosh Todd I'm glad
you finally asked now I I often wonder
if I had to ask what would have happened
would he had just gone home that day but
he goes oh my gosh Dad I'm glad you
finally asked and then he it was it was
a like a briefcase like you know just
like like you're a spy or something and
then he clicked it open
and you're waiting for the CIA folder
except for there wasn't no CIA folders
it was
two baseball gloves and a ball
and one of the gloves was left-handed
and he turns to me and he goes I heard
you're a pretty good baseball player
Todd and I went yeah yeah I I played
back then Eddie and he goes you want to
play catch during lunch break and I want
sure I can play catch with Eddie Vedder
that's cool
because Eddie's a big baseball nut right
and so he had done his homework and he
knew it and he knew I was left-handed
and he had like I said if I'd never
asked him about it would he have ever
opened it but then it goes even further
we finally go outside and unfortunately
it's seasonably hot it's like about 105
106 that day in California but I'm from
Phoenix it doesn't matter I can deal but
Eddie has got black boots black pants
black shirt black sunglasses and he's
smoking if you've ever seen that scene
of John Candy in the movie Splash where
he's trying to play handball and he's
drinking and whatever and he's having a
heart attack while he's playing
we start going and at about minute eight
I could see he's starting to slow down
and the throws you're not quite with the
authority and it gets slower and then he
starts breathing heavier and then pretty
soon I go Eddie
lets you take a break and he's like
yeah okay if you want to if you want to
and then he sits down and he
and I mean I thought I'd go I'm gonna
kill this man we keep playing he
literally is going to pass out with heat
exhaustion you're gonna have to rush him
to the hospital and it was like but he
wasn't gonna give him this is a dumb
thing about boys in our testosterone
neither one of us looking to give but
I'm a cockroach I could have gone all
day until I killed them right so I just
pulled it back I didn't feel like being
the guy that was the one that sent Eddie
to the hospital had to cancel his
because they were on they were on tour
at that point so he just came in for a
couple of days so I didn't want to be
the bad guy but anyways Eddie wasn't
quite smart enough to go dress
appropriately and don't smoke when
you're exerting yourself physically but
and so that video goes on to I don't
know how many views it has now on
YouTube like 50 plus a million views on
YouTube so we'll link to that in the
show notes where does all of this lead
right so this is your first foray into
music
and you're animating which means you're
directing but that comes from the HBO
right so again this is right it comes
from the HBO you do Marvel that begat
Image Comics image begat right I'm gonna
use biblical terms
spawn spawn begat HBO HBO because Eddie
was watching it begats hey you want to
do a music video music video comes out
successful gets nominated for a Grammy
that begets people phoning hey you want
to do more music video right I mean so
it all just becomes this weird accident
that just starts tumbling and these
doors of opportunity open up where you
never knew they were ever going to open
up before right so none of it's planned
yeah it's just happy accidents along the
way
and doing a good job on each piece of it
so that those doors
open or present themselves so let's talk
about that piece let's talk about that
because what you just said is important
so sometimes I get people go oh Todd you
know you're you're just sort of getting
rich and famous and you just want to you
gotta ego whatever else and it's like
and probably that's true but let me tell
you why I like success not because I
want some more money I've got it not
because I need a bigger ego I've got
plenty of people who've said nice things
about me for plenty of years I'm over me
right nobody's more border Todd than me
so here's why success matters because
you can't keep doing art which is what I
am an artist if I walk into the room and
say oh get this the last thing I did
failed you don't get the job you have to
have a certain level of success to get
the next job that's why I need to keep
the momentum that's why I need to have
success not for the fame or the fortune
that's just a byproduct I need it so I
can do art again tomorrow and the next
day and the next day and hopefully if if
I do it right I'll die and I have been
doing art till the time I take my last
breath that's the success so the art and
the success has to be a component you're
not dealing with HBO and the NFL and
Microsoft and all these companies we've
dealt with if you're not able to show
that you can do the job at a level that
makes sense for them so I'm not going to
apologize for us doing our jobs right
yeah it doesn't seem to be your style
all right so we're talking about
these
these multiple encounters with
are very nice friend dumb luck but it's
not really as somebody put it to me once
I can't remember exactly who it was I
wish I could get an attribution but they
talk about the surface area of luck so
by doing certain things you can sort of
increase the surface area that is
available for luck to stick to and I
think I agree you've done a very good
job with that
so where do games or movies
enter into this entire
constellation of activities let's go
back to the dumb like just for a minute
to just paint a metaphor again
I'm at half court
and I got my back to the basket and I
throw it backwards and then I make the
bucket and they're like oh Todd you're a
genius some people look at that and go
your Genius I'm going that's a little
bit of dumb luck but to your point the
reason that I was able to get that
genius shot that some people think of
because I was there for four days in a
row and I took 10 000 shots and I missed
every other one right but I didn't leave
until I made the shot so if you take 10
000 shots
sometimes one of them goes in so there's
the personality of going when they say
no which is basically a missed shot
don't do it Todd oh yeah I'm going to
shoot again you can't do that I'm going
to shoot again you can't you can't shoot
shoot shoot and then bam every now and
then you sync one and then you go how do
I build off that because people saw that
you put it up on Tick Tock and it's like
you don't show all of your misses on all
those tick tocks you want to show the
one you made you don't know how many
years or hours or months they spent
until they made that one shot business a
little bit is like that so again it's a
perceived skill because when you see the
one shot on Tick Tock you think they're
super awesome because you didn't see the
three days they didn't make it right so
there's a little bit of that going going
on there so back to your question sorry
actually let's before we get to games
and movies and how that
sort of coalesced or entered the scene
in some way let's talk about creating
characters or fictional worlds that
endure for decades and in doing research
for this I've found
an interview
a viewers where you talked about going
into Hollywood and pitching various
ideas and you were I might be misquoting
so I can't can't believe everything you
read on the internet but
the the section here that I'd love to
hear you elaborate on is so these people
in the meeting go what's the end of it
and my answer is I don't give a [ __ ]
what's the end of Superman what's the
end of Batman what's the end of
Spider-Man why are you asking me for the
end why why aren't you asking can this
last for 30 years and it goes on but
could you just speak to
building something that endures and how
that informs maybe decisions you make or
how you think about
creativity well that quote that you
spoke is true and I've had that
conversation many many times in
Hollywood it's weird that you're walking
in presenting them the beginning of an
idea and one of their first questions is
how does the idea end for a company a
studio
a conglomerate who's built on trying to
make money it's like why would you want
to kill anything in the crib it's a
weird conversation I'm having with them
because again what is the end of Batman
I don't know who cares we hope it goes a
thousand years like why are we talking
about this in the first meeting I mean I
get it maybe in season three and the
ratings are lagging we can we can maybe
have this conversation but not in the
first one so I think one of the ways to
create a brand that
does have some value is using another
word and it's called attrition and
attrition is that over time you're going
to have both high points and low points
but you got to just keep going you can't
quit you got to just keep going and
going and going and going and find
yourself and put yourself in as many
corners as possible during both the good
and the bad time so that maybe people
don't know who you are or don't know
what you do but then they go you know
what I yeah no I've heard the character
spawn they don't have to have bought
anything right
I'm gonna use a big example
I know and have read nothing about the
Kardashians and yet I have information
in my head about that
I've done nothing towards that and still
it's in my head why because I can't get
away from them and somehow as I'm
looking for an article I read the
headline and so I've got info
that's just attrition and so were people
going did the Spawn comic book have a
lull at times of course it did where the
sales were not very good of course it
did
but I thought that the value of wasn't
that was I making money in the way that
I needed to at that point it was just to
keep the Machinery going because the
value at some point isn't now any single
issue or any single year it's now the
sum total of all of it so that all the
people over 30 years who have passed
through any of the characters I've
created lets you spawn he's my biggest
guy so maybe they came in for five years
and then quit but they're still there
they're still there right so if we ever
do a movie
they're gonna remember oh yeah yeah 20
years ago I collected but maybe it was
somebody who passed through it 15 years
ago or 10 years ago or five years ago or
just jumped on since we set the world
record that came in going huh you know
what I've been a DC and Marvel acolyte
now I'm going to sort of try this out I
don't care all you want to do is
collectively keep building so that when
you go to your next move you can maybe
peel off a piece of that Army off to the
side so to me it now it's just it's just
attrition of just going again again
again
and so it will just get into your brain
I'll give you a bad bad bad example
early on I mentioned it before when I
was at my first toy fair I gave them a
Hot Wheel
in the car I don't know if people know
what a funny car is but a funny car is
like a cut down Dragster and they put
this really cool fiberglass body and
they go down just Google what's a funny
car look like they're super cool we used
to when I grew up in Orange County
Orange County International Raceway we
used to go down there funny cars was the
coolest thing in my life way better than
dragons and robots anyways I bought it I
bought a funny car when spawn came out
and really because I wanted I wanted a
funny car but I had to convince my wife
and other people otherwise so it was
like no it's not that I need a funny car
it's just that if I take a funny car and
I paint the word spawn on it and I take
it to shows you know who has a funny car
at comic book conventions no one you
know who's ever had a funny card comic
book conventions no one if you bring
something to a show that nobody's ever
brought before you'll be surprised like
if you bring a elephant
to a comic book convention and paint it
purple people will actually look at it
they'll come and look at it because
they'll be going why you got a purple
elephant here so my purple elephant my
pink elephant literally was the funny
car now here's what I did
one side I did a two two-tone paint job
on it one side was white with the word
spawn on it and it had like blood like
you hit a deer at a thousand miles an
hour and it splattered over the white
the other side was black with flames
because it's super cool and then what I
used to do Tim is I used to have it sort
of centered in my big giant booth and
then I had this piece of paper and it
said vote which side do you like better
so I can finish this project
and here's what people did
they went and they went and I saw it
with my own eyes hundreds of times they
took their kid or was it Trump one
person and they went on the white side
and yeah that's kind of cool with the
blood I like it and I like the fade and
they went over to the flame black side
yeah like that but you know man let me
see let me go back over there no maybe I
like that one and it went back and forth
back and forth and then they marked the
sheet you know what I did with the sheet
at the end of each show I threw it in
the garbage I threw in the garbage I
didn't give a [ __ ] I didn't I was never
gonna repaint that car what I needed
them to do Tim was to spend five minutes
looking at my logo and if I had painted
that car with one paint job the same on
both sides they wouldn't have looked at
it for five minutes
so I forced them to look at the word
spawn thinking that they were helping me
on some polling survey and it was just I
need to get the word spawn into their
Wormhole and this this is my trick so if
you just figure out iterations of that
how do you get people to do that then
eventually over time time matters time
does matter time becomes the biggest
value you have on your brand
so from a creative let's just say
writing standpoint you've
now published more of than 300
editions of
spawn right
how many books out when you started
spawn how many books out had you planned
from a plot or character perspective and
how much of it was setting conditions
and making it cool and then assuming
you're just going to figure it out later
and see where it goes like how how far
in advance
did you or do you plan with that kind of
thing
Tim I just finished what's going to be
the biggest comic book in the country
just last week the Batman spawn
crossover we touched upon it hmm I was
winging it until they pried it out of my
hand on Tuesday what are you talking
about like it horrifies writers the way
that I do it is horrifying do I have it
in my head of course not I just
figured out on the Fly and luckily I get
it right more times I get it wrong so
here's what the goal was when I started
spawn
there's two goals one we started the
company Image Comics the third largest
company as I mentioned
I said to myself when we started that
image comic books will exist for my
lifetime
and how do I know that because even if
there was only one book called spawn I
was never going to take that logo off so
I knew it was going to exist because I'm
just that militant I'm putting it on
issue number one and it will never come
off so image comic book somehow maybe in
a small tiny way will exist obviously
we're flourishing so I don't have to
worry about there only been one book
because we do about 60 or 70 books a
month
number two
could I create a character
that would outlive me
period
the guy who created Superman is dead the
guy who created Mickey Mouse dead the
guy who created The Fantastic Four we
talked about him earlier today Stanley
dead their characters live on right I
consider
Creations to be creative children and
every parent has the same wish you
always want your children to outlive you
right you always want your children to
outlive you why no parent gets up saying
I hope my children go before I do you
always want to go you will set we've
seen movies I'll sacrifice my life right
Women and Children First you'll
sacrifice your life for your family but
you go first if these are creative
children then the goal is because I I
read about these people who created
these characters that I know about but
their creators have long since passed
away including my good friend Stan could
I create one or two characters I don't
need a hundred I'm not Disney I'm not
Walt Disney I'm not Stanley I'm not that
good but could I create one or two
characters that when I die people say I
still want to see the characters that
was that was the goal in in the back of
my head and so did I have a plan of
where it was going no not really did I
have a plan of how it was going to end
of course what you know I do actually
have the end I just never have given it
to anybody and I hope it never gets
written because the only time you write
the end is if nobody wants it so you go
ah I guess we better write the last
story and put it to bed or whatever else
now to the point Tim
and I I I hate sort of saying this out
loud but
spawn's costume was alive it's like a
symbiote it moves and the chains are
like the tongue and the spikes are like
the teeth and the Cape is all alive was
his costume alive in issue number one no
no
how did it become alive
you just hit these moments real quickly
people were right in because I'm I'm
very lazy I never did a lot of
referencing you know there was no
internet but I I still didn't go to the
library and get reference I had
deadlines don't have time for it I just
fake everything so I was drawing my
pages of issue number one and I guess
that's how bad I am I don't pay
attention to my own drawings
and so people were writing in going Todd
Todd you know you had the pouch on his
left leg and now it's on his right leg
do you know that you had six spikes on
his arm and now it's like got eight
spikes and so there's these are easy
moments Tim that you have two choices
you either admit you're a dumb [ __ ] or
you go
that's because
it's alive the costume morphs and it can
do anything at any time it's a living
being and that's now part of the
mythology and it was just because I
screwed up what are you talking about
you just you make lemonade out of your
lemons and you just keep moving on and
hope they don't catch up to you I've
been in those rooms plenty of times
where I said something I shouldn't have
and they go
I'll give you an example I was at doing
a movie Pitch for something and I think
it was for Doom or something and I was
given this pitch and they discovered
something underneath the Mojave Desert
or whatever I was on a rant and my buddy
next to me slides a piece of paper over
to me I'm right in the middle of it I'm
with the Warner Brothers people and the
prior writers because they brought me in
to see if they could help spark it and
he slides a piece of paper over to me
and as I'm standing up and the honor
that says Todd it takes place on the
moon or something like that I'm I'm
going and they discover it in the Mojave
Desert I'm actually off a lot of miles
and I'm like I just blow the whole
premise of this book and I'd go well
I'm this deep I gotta I can't I gotta
keep going and I sit down and I remember
the executive at Warner Brothers like
looks at me for a couple seconds dead
silence and then he goes slaps his hand
and goes that's what I'm talking about
he's not he's not afraid to take chances
he's not afraid and the answer was I
just didn't do enough research sadly
otherwise I would have put it on the
moon so sometimes you just have to if
you say it with enough confidence
they'll go along for the ride with it
and it's like he's not afraid to
basically follow everything in the book
this is what I've been talking about
we've got to bend some of the rules blah
blah blah so anyway
spawn we're up to issue 336 went to the
printers a couple days ago do I know
what 337 is I write a book called
gunsling response
do I know what the next issue is nope I
know there's a guy I just introduced a
cliffhanger with a guy who runs fast
that's all I know that I gotta pick up
with a guy who runs fast so I'll figure
it out when I've got to get the plot in
two days so
and 10 years from now you and I may be
talking about our my Speedster Runner
who's the most popular guy I had no idea
the day before what I was doing with
them so
well Todd where do you want to go next
I'll leave it up to you I mean you've
got so many stories you seemingly have
so many lives that run in tandem you're
an excellent five ball juggler
so which ball if any would you like to
talk about next
what if we get away from the businesses
and talk about personalities not mine
but other people right I think that that
what's a value to people who are
thinking about doing ideas and or some
entrepreneurship is
to some extent recognizing your own
personalities of whether you're
actually Built For War or not and to me
all of this is a war I know my wife has
said I it's sort of sad you see your
life is a war every day
and so I'm I'm ready and if I've got one
regret
I've got few of them but one of them is
I wish I was born
3 000 years ago because back then like
in a movie like Braveheart if you
believed in something so strongly you
would go to the battlefield you would
face your enemy who basically was trying
to deny you whatever it was that would
give you personal happiness or what you
thought would be good for your family
and only two things were going to happen
you were either gonna cut his head off
or he was going to cut yours
that simple and I've always been the guy
willing to go I'll die I'll die for what
I believe now unfortunately Tim
killing your enemy and cutting her head
off is illegal right and it's really
frustrating to me because man there's a
lot of heads I'd like to see on the
ground but I and I'm sure they'd like to
see mine but we can't do that we have to
be a law-abiding citizen so now what we
have to do in modern times is sue people
and take away market shares and tell
them you will never work in this town
and it's just not nearly as satisfying
as if I could just cut their heads off
so if I get ready for the war which
means that every day and here's I'm
going to give you a piece of advice that
don't tell your mom if you're listening
to me because moms will be horrified by
this here here it is lower the bar
lower
the bar don't raise the bar Lower it
here's why
way easier to get over low bars than it
is high bars try it put a bar six feet
high try to jump over it put a bar six
inches off the ground you can get over
it 20 times in a minute it's easy lower
the bar ladies and gentlemen so
that means that I get up every day and I
don't have high expectations of anything
not even with Humanity so here's I'm not
a religious person but I do have sort of
a personal prayer and it's sort of this
simple every day today will not
be perfect
and you know many days in a row Tim I've
nailed that
every single day of my life I have no
I'm on like even a longer streak than
Cal Ripken Jr with that what tortures
people and some of you are listening are
the people who have the bar higher than
that
did you see this email this guy sent me
that son of a [ __ ] oh you thought today
was gonna be perfect did you see that
guy that guy cut me off on the freeway
right oh that guy cut me off here
in line I was waiting in line and they
cut me off getting a ticket for them for
the Black Panther movie and now I can't
get in or whatever oh oh somebody said
something about my haircut somebody said
something about that like what so you
thought that the world was going to be
perfect and that everybody was going to
wake up and that they were going to make
your life better you know who woke up in
the planet today with eight billion
people and said I'm gonna make Todd's
life better today there was only one
human being one and that was me no other
human being not even my wife that was
their mission today that was me so if
you're expecting others to make you
happy and and make it accommodating for
you you're gonna get crushed so here's
what I would say lower the bar go to
your job interview and before you walk
in give it your damnedest but assume
you're not getting the job
give it your damndest but assume you're
not getting it so when they don't phone
you back and when you don't get the job
you're okay with it because if anything
you actually take it as a pride that you
actually called the shot
I knew it I knew it I went there they
didn't give it to me dumb [ __ ] but I
knew it and pretty soon you don't get
hired for 10 20 jobs in a row and you're
on a hot streak now you're actually
feeling pretty good that you called it
20 times in a row you're not getting the
job and then guess what happens
you go to the 21st interview and you
give it your best and you walk away and
they go Todd where are you going
I'm out of here because I know you're
not gonna hire me and they go no
we actually want to offer you a job and
here's why that's an awesome day because
well it's sort of kind of caused it
frustrate first off they break my streak
of 20 no's in a row so I'm a little
frustrated that my streak went away
because I'm like God damn it they broke
my streak but by breaking my streak I
got the job I got the job it's a good
day here's what most people do Tim and
my family members do the same thing and
I can't help them it's personality they
actually think they're going to get
every job they go and apply for and when
they don't they get crushed it literally
crushes their soul for two or three days
and they're just
they're a shell of a person why because
they put the bar High the bar was that
we were going to get the job no put the
bar where it says I'm not getting the
job and you will never be disappointed
assume today is not going to be perfect
and assume human beings are flawed and
you will have a
pretty damn good life because guess what
happens some days nobody Cuts you off
nobody cuts in line and nobody writes
you a bad email and it's a pretty good
day it's a pretty good day because
sort of discomfort didn't come not that
you won the lottery not that you didn't
that your team won the championship you
just didn't have a lot of aggravation
you didn't get sued today cool it's a
good day I don't know it I I psyched
myself out I psych myself out
for little success so when any of it
comes it's cool we talked about it with
selling the toys at sixty thousand
there's either way to get to sixty
thousand sales and it be a negative or
it can be a positive it depends on how
you psych yourself out I am a horrible
golfer horrible golfer I don't do it
much
also I've had people say Todd you're the
worst golfer who doesn't care here's why
I don't care because I don't Golf and so
I don't golf I don't assume I'm Gonna
Get Better by not golfing every three
years any more than my Mandarin and my
Spanish is going to get better by me not
practicing either one of those languages
either you don't get better by not doing
it so when I go golf the odd time I'm in
Phoenix I'm horrible but every now and
then I get lucky and all of a sudden I
get a par five I get a six I am dancing
naked when I get a six on a on a par
five and but but it's interesting with
another guy who must have had a
different expectation his bar was
different than mine he hits it he hits
it he gets a six and he is so mad he
actually breaks his club that costs more
than my entire rental
and he breaks his club and I'm sitting
there going wow he got a six I got a six
it's the same number I'm dancing naked
and he's cursing up a storm he must have
had a different expectation than me so
that's it I just keep my expectations
low It Gets You Through there
so number two they're always going to
say no to you always going to say no to
you there has never been a story written
in which the person who had the new idea
the person in the lead said oh I will
now slow down or get out of the way so
you can pass me
never ever will happen so if you're
gonna do something that's gonna
aggravate the system status quo there's
never been anybody in history that's
ever changed anything on any level and
was liked by everybody get over it get
over people liking you right just figure
out what your goal is I'll give you my
personality I take my wife we're gonna
go to the bar and we're gonna go dance
okay nine o'clock comes around the band
starts playing nobody wants to be the
first one on the Dance Floor let me also
say if you've never been the first one
on the Dance Floor you're probably not
built to be an entrepreneur
let me just let me just sort of put that
there because that means you give a [ __ ]
about the rest of the people in that
room
I don't
and here's why first off I don't even
know why why would I give any weight why
would I give any power to a stranger
in my life
here's what my goal is my goal was to
take my lovely wife out for an evening
of dancing
there's a dance floor and there's music
I'm gonna dance if every other human
being in that room doesn't want to dance
I don't care if they all want to dance I
don't care none of them are of
importance to me what's important is
that I want to dance with my wife
tonight and I'm doing it I'm doing it
do I care whether they think I'm a good
dancer nope do I care if they think I
look like a goof nope nope not one
second of power do I give to that person
if you're the person that's gonna wait
till the dance floor is full so that
then you can get on and nobody will see
you so you can hide in the middle of the
pack I'm just telling you you're
probably not built to be an entrepreneur
right you have to just be at times
like literally
don't care
and it's not a trait that I want to
encourage I don't want my kids to be
like me but you have to have it because
if you're going to make change if you're
going to go up against competition
they're gonna every day try and tell you
you can't and try and embarrass you
somehow and you have to just push it and
categorize it to a side and say
I don't care this is my goal and I'm
going to do it anyways
now why would you not want your kids to
have that trade what's the downside how
do you think about that because I can be
a cold fish
at times when needed cold fish right
meaning too Spock like like when you
come off as unemotional no no I I told
you let's say you put me out tomorrow
and I could cut the heads of my enemies
let's go back to Braveheart and I could
cut the heads of my enemy right
so I got my my mortal enemy he's in
front of me and I cut his head off do
you know how much time I'm gonna give to
feeling guilty that I did it zero
seconds you know why Tim because I'm in
the middle of a battle remember I keep
thinking I'm at War and if you watch
something like Braveheart I'm not the
only one and they're not the only one on
the battlefield and if I sit there and
give time to feel sorry for what I did
to that man and think about his family
and his children
somebody's coming up behind me is going
to cut my head off and I will be dead
six seconds later so I must learn to cut
and turn
and forget about that dead Victim
Because somebody's out to kill me five
seconds later and I either survive or at
least attempt to survive or I lament and
get my head cut off in a second here's
how this works Tim here's how this works
in Practical modern terms for a guy like
Todd and I don't necessarily want
anybody to do it I'm just telling you
who I am
I usually phone
lawyers that I don't like and I'm in a
fight with on Friday about 4 30. this is
actually a very good time here's why
it's a good time
because I can get on the phone with them
and they can argue and then you start
raising voices and you start sound like
Mussolini on the balcony and you start
going and you usually end those
conversations like oh yeah well [ __ ] you
yeah well [ __ ] you okay I'll get on the
phone with you Monday we're going to
sell this [ __ ] and you go click now
here's what I've told my wife because
she's heard me do this before she goes
Todd she's heard me before Todd you're
gonna have a heart attack no I'm not
yes you're gonna have a heart attack no
I'm not and here's why my wife's name is
Wanda no Wanda I'm not gonna have a
heart attack and she doesn't believe
this until this one scary moment that I
go no and she goes why I go because I
don't care
the moment I hang up that phone click
I don't even care about that guy
that that lawyer I just yelled at click
he's like like dude it's the weekend's
coming I worry about him on Monday I
worry about him on Monday so but but
because I can do that here's here's what
happens to the lawyer he gets off the
phone he goes to all of his people in
the office he goes I just got off the
phone with this son of a [ __ ] and
here's what he said and he's going to
chew on it and he's going to chew on it
then he's going to go home and his
wife's gonna say how was your day oh
fine except for at the end this guy and
he's going to chew on it and then
they're gonna go out and you're gonna
have a barbecue with their friends and
then go how are you going oh fine but I
got this one thing and he's going to
chew on it and chew on it and he's gonna
sit there and think about me the whole
weekend and by Monday he's exhausted and
you know how much time I gave him during
that same amount of time not one
second of my emotions why because on
Monday click I turn it back on and guess
between the two of us who's emotionally
more stronger to continue the
conversation the guy who was in the gym
the whole time bench pressing that
weight or the guy who put it down and
let his muscle sort of relax so I can go
back to the gym a couple days later I
don't care and here's how I know that's
true I know it's true you can believe it
or not but I I proved it to my wife one
day she took out a life insurance policy
or something and the doctors have to
come to the house and they have to do an
exam on you to make sure that you're not
dying or whatever so they come and they
got to do an examination on me and my
wife and my wife is top fit she's she's
awesome she's like a hiker Runner you
know she's like a model she's awesome
anyways they came and I was in the
middle of one of these Mussolini moments
and the doctors came and go Todd you
gotta examine you and I go tell them to
do Wanda first I'm on the phone I'm on
the phone
until they go and do Wanda
and then they do my wife whatever they
had to do and then they come upstairs
and and she knows she can still hear me
yelling and she comes up with the
doctors there's a couple of them and
then they go okay I taught at you and I
go yeah oh yeah okay and it's like and
[ __ ] you click I'd end my conversation I
go what are we doing oh we got to do
this examination oh yeah okay cool and
they and this is my wife was waiting for
and they do the blood pressure and they
do all the testing and they go oh yours
is the same as your wife
I literally and it horrified my wife let
me just tell you it horrified her
because she goes I am married a she was
happy that I'm not gonna die of a heart
attack because I literally can turn the
switch off two she was horrified she's
married to a monster that he literally
doesn't care about another human being
and can just turn it off I turn it off
Tim not out of Pride not because I think
that's the way to go not because I think
that's it it's because we all if you're
in war and I think I'm in war if you're
at War you have to find out ways of
surviving that work for you this is how
I've learned to survive to not let any
I've been sued I've been screamed out
I've had people threatened the other day
what are you talking about one of the
big retailers threatened to take all my
toys off their show you just you just
accept that this is just part of the
world that you live in and if at any
time Tim
I ever get aggravated you know who I'm
the most aggravated with me
because at the end no matter what's
happening I have to ask the same
question
who put me in this position it's
uncomfortable I don't want to be here
why am I arguing with lawyers today oh
that was you Todd you started that
company you kept it going you kept doing
it I don't get to pass the buck and so I
have to sit there and say
guy who basically caused all this is the
guy I shave with every day and here's
the problem with that I actually like
that dude and even if I don't I gotta
live with him for the rest of my natural
life so you know what I'm stuck I'm
stuck with it and so I just figure out
ways that work for me I don't want you
or any listener to replicate it I would
I would say no what I do do when I go to
business classes which is super awesome
when I go talk to business classes at
University first thing I say is I'm not
going to tell you how to make money
85 percent of them throw their pencil
down and disgust
because they thought I was going to give
them the 10 lessons and how to make
money I go here's what we're going to
talk about for an hour how to keep your
Humanity
how to actually be a reasonable human
being so here's what I'm going to tell
you
I would rather you become a
garbage collector and go become a good
Community person and go coach
low link for free
then to be the the VP of a bank and be
divorced four times and estranged from
your family and nobody wants to hang out
with you we somehow equate in North
America money to success and to me my
definition of success is different right
I just I just think that there's a way
to just not care even if you do have
money and Prestige and all of it to me
it's all silly it's all it's all
complicated Our Lives my my wife will
tell you the same it was easier when
life was simpler but it's it's you guys
are built the guys that are doing their
mbas in these classes they're just
little baby sharks and when I'm given
that conversation I know that they I
want to emulate the big shark so I'm
only talking to four or five of them
that are out there and at the end of it
after we sort of go with it I sometimes
sort of do this last little question
there I go I'm just going to leave you
with one thing because I know about
making money you got to make money and
the reason I don't want to tell you how
to make money because if I tell you how
to make a million bucks you and your
brain and your intellect and your
personal experiences might have figured
out how to make 100 million why would I
try to tell you how to make a million
you might have made 100 million you may
be a thousand times smarter than me I
don't want to limit you right so but let
me just leave once we talked all this
sort of to see if we can't leave you
with one thought here
all of you just woke up tomorrow and
you're not feeling very good so you go
to the you go to the doctors and doctors
takes you in the back room and he does a
bunch of blood tests and says hey I'm
going to run the blood test and you go
sit out in the lobby I'll get back to
you so you go out in the lobby and you
look on your cell phone for a while and
then 25 minutes later the doctor comes
back it doesn't look very good it's got
a serious look and he says hey I need
you to come back to my office yeah sure
doc and you go sit down they go we ran
all the tests
and we re-round them and you have
inoperable cancer and there is nothing
modern medicine can do you will be dead
in three weeks you're dead
there's no hope
now
I'm gonna assume that everybody
listening to my voice right now has at
least one person they care about
at least one person so think about the
person that you care about the most
that person I assume if you care for
them that that much they care about you
that much and in three weeks that person
is going to be left without you it will
be trauma to their life
so here's the question
if you could only pick one human being
to help that person you care about to
transition after you're gone to soft
land them as much as possible to be by
their side to do anything that will be
helpful in their grieving period
who is that individual I want you to
pick just one individual I'll give you
15 seconds to think of it and then I
stand there
in silence
and then I go my last question before I
leave
did you pick the richest person you know
or did you pick the best person
why don't you want to be the second one
why don't you want to be the best person
instead of the richest because when it
mattered and we just proved it
you didn't pick the rich person
be the second person
and you can still make money and be that
second person don't worry about it but
don't make the money the driver don't do
it but I'm only talking to three of you
in this class the rest you've already
sold your soul
well Todd I think that is the best place
to maybe bring this conversation home
and leave people with that to chew on
without adding too much more I have to
say we could easily do around three at
some point but I do think that is an
excellent place to
stop and begin to at least land the plan
is there anything else that you would
like to
add
call people's attention to or anything
else any closing comments before we
end this conversation at least for now
the only thing I'd like to do is
encourage people
who have a little bit of doubt if you
got a lot of bit of doubt it might not
work a little bit of doubt I think we
can get past that hurdle
I don't consider myself to be smarter
intelligent or do better anything better
than anybody else and I was able through
just
a little bit of perseverance to sort of
get there I I believe that if I can do
it and I was dumb I got nothing but
these you know in school and stuff like
that if I can do it I just I just think
there are so many people up there and
what I do at times it's frustrating to
me
I'm up on stage sometimes at comma
conventions I don't even talk about
comic books but I I go I'm going to talk
to you as your dad is your uncle and I'm
going to tell you why I think you should
try this and I think we've spoken about
some of those on your show in these two
parts right just just try it and if it
doesn't work it's like cutting your hair
to grow back you can always go back to
the system wherever you're at you can
always go back there's no there's no
harm there's no
dishonesty and trying and failing that's
okay right the person who never tries I
think sort of has more regret
so I talked to him I stand on one side
of the stage and I go you know come on
man I I just try try it once I think
everybody in honesty Tim should to try
to be an entrepreneur once in their life
and then I walk to the other stage
and I go now I'm going to talk to you is
Todd the CEO I hope you don't do it I
hope you sow those doubts and you never
do it and you know why because that
means I will never have to compete with
you and you may be smarter and better
and more well equipped and I'll never
have to play the game against you so
make my life easy and don't compete but
I'm telling you the dad side of me take
me down man because because the 25 year
old Todd I'm telling you I just know
would have would have listened to me the
60 year old man and would have said dude
I will gut you I try like I would never
have let an old man on that stage go I
hope you don't do it because you're not
good enough like I would have I would
have gone and said oh yeah I've made it
my personal mission so even if even if I
can just gin up
a couple of people to just go come on
man come on man you can do it but if you
keep coming up with reasons why you're
not built for entrepreneurship
you have to think a little bit
delusional at times to the point where
you think you're better than you are
that's okay that's okay confidence is
half the battle and now we got to figure
out whether you got the skill sets which
is the other half but some of the skill
can come along the way because
confidence
and determination can take you pretty
far until you learn those skills so just
go go go that's all I've got
well done
I will say first that I can see why the
people from the NHL or wherever would
have said yeah I think we'll just take
the 500 Grand
and not choose to have this guy uh
jabbing us with a spear for the next uh
20 years so let's just do that deal I
can definitely see that and I find you
to be extremely impressive as Creator as
an artist
fascinating as a CEO and I gotta say
you're a hell of a good teacher you're a
really good teacher so thank you for
taking the time to have these
conversations and to share your stories
and your lessons and your beliefs it's
been a hell of a lot of fun
and to everybody listening we will have
links to everything we discussed
all the music videos anything else that
my team and I can possibly find as a
reference to link to related to the show
we'll include in the show notes at
tim.blog podcast as usual you can find
Todd on all the social networks we'll
link to those in the show notes as well
at team.blog podcast and until next time
get out there give it a shot take your
shot you'll miss all the shots you don't
take so give it a go you can always go
back to the system in the status quo and
thanks for listening
thank you for listening everybody and
huge thanks to Todd for coming on the
show I could do part three part four and
part five with Todd maybe I will before
you go just one announcement I've been
up to all sorts of shenanigans and I
have been stretching some creative
muscles my fiction writing is now live
on a brand new podcast called [ __ ] punch
Yes you heard that right as you think
it's spelled [ __ ] punch it is based on a
fictional World a fantasy world that
I've created and the podcast launched
last week with a very short and bizarre
trailer and it debuted at number one in
the fiction category on Apple podcast
and has been in the top 100 for all
podcasts on Apple podcasts in the US and
many other countries all of last week
that was the case it is the first
podcast I've launched in many years the
first few episodes are super short
roughly five minutes each and I would
love if you check it out take a look
it's strange you might enjoy it you can
find the show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you listen to podcasts or
simply go to cockpunch.com podcast for
all the links the entire podcast is
intended to add some laughter and levity
to a world dominated by what we all do
if we don't have anything better to
distract us Doom scrolling pessimism
nihilism there's too much of that so
take a look find it all at cockpunch.com
podcast